and
he is going to to really describe what
he saw he has he has come clean he has
come out of this
um this sort of militia cult that he was
part of for a long time and stephen
ayers steven ayers a as we've described
him a defendant in the january sixth
insurrection
very interesting point here one of his
co-defendants a guy named matthew perna
committed suicide after pleading guilty
i just want to remind everybody what a
death cult the mega movement is
we know about brian sicknick we know
about the other capitol police officers
and metropolitan police officers that
committed suicide in the fallout it is
so tragic
and just unfathomable what they had to
go through on that day but never forget
that this is a death cult for donald
trump's own supporters as well how many
of his own supporters did he send to
death that day ashley babbitt roseanne
boylan kevin griese and benjamin
phillips this gentleman matthew perna
committed suicide after pleading guilty
this is what following donald trump who
will use anyone and everything to his
own advantage for
nobody else's good it will do to you
so um we're going to see all of these
links and i'm really looking forward to
it
well i appreciate your insight there um
a great breakdown of the witnesses and
some of the uh connections there uh ben
what do you make of some of those some
of those actually you know before i
before i go there i want to point out
because there was some debate last night
about your hat that you had on um on on
the podcast we have a screenshot
well i don't have a screenshot i wish i
did i i did post a screenshot on twitter
where did you get that hat where did you
get that head on last night it's a
sombrero i got it in kakula mexico near
guadalajara okay okay cause there was
some debate i called it a cowboy hat
jessica here uh corrected me in that
it's not a cowboy head um i'm i'm from
you know the country and it to me it
looked looked much like a cowboy hat um
we're going to have another cowboy hat
here really soon but now before i also i
i'm getting i'm getting uh someone
begging me to to mention the the
pro-democracy unapologetically
pro-democracy enamel pens human made in
the usa go to store.mindustutch.com for
10 off just use the promo code justice
for 10 off the brand new new release pro
democracy unapologetically pro-democracy
union made pens i hope that satisfies
them yeah those are fresh those are
fresh
and whenever we put out the new pins
they like they sell like that so if you
want one of those pro democracy pins go
and get them now
i know jordy wanted me to push that so
he's the marketing guy you know he's got
a push for the market i know he's not
here today so i figured we would
get at least given this dude why isn't
he here today
yeah yeah does he work over there
besides uh coming up with new pen ideas
or what's going on jordan is getting
something i
issue that jessica wright if he's going
to be testifying as a fact witness um
and the things that he observed that are
outside the scope of his attorney-client
privilege so the deal he cut is that he
wasn't going to reveal things that were
truly in connection with legal advice
and anticipation of litigation but that
what he would do is hey i was in the
room and i saw all these other things
happen and things were said because the
attorney-client privilege is a very
sacred privilege between person and
attorney so if other people are in the
room and it's not for legal advice the
attorney-client privilege does not apply
and those are the types of questions
that sipolone was going to agree it was
by the way it wasn't a foregone
conclusion that simpoloni was even going
to testify to that remember that liz
cheney had called him out in an earlier
hearing and said we need to hear from
pat simpoloni it took cassidy
hutchinson's bravery for sibolone to
basically stop obstructing it took the
prosecution of bannon and seeing what
was happening to how serious the doj was
for people like sipoloni to testify and
just finally tony going to
the one tweet that donald trump wrote
about this is going to be wild i want
people listening to think just what a
criminal act this was what a dereliction
of duty imagine if you knew when you got
word and you could go back in time like
right before the oklahoma city bomb
right you know timothy mcveigh and his
group of terrorists was going to be at a
location and you as the president if
bill clinton said hey everybody let's go
hang out here things are gonna get wild
okay it's really no different than that
he knew that a group that was
being watched by the fbi by
the government for
engaging in terroristic acts was going
to be at a location and put people's
lives in jeopardy and the president of
the united states says it's going to be
wild i mean how sick and disgusting can
you possibly be and how sick and
disgusting can you be as a person to
support somebody like that right brett
well brett we've seen we've seen that
the president the former president
continued to do this stuff in his little
nazi excuse me his rally that he had in
alaska over the weekend he kept he kept
trying to stoke this
this type of terrorism that isn't state
funded or
or state related it's only hey well you
know it's kind of the if you punch them
i'll pay your legal fees type stuff you
know that we've seen from the 2016
campaign it's kind of the same
the same stuff over and over and over
again from trump but he's all in he's
all in at this point i mean what's he
going to do all of a sudden at this
point in the game he's going to say oh i
was wrong election was actually all good
uh sorry about that sorry for the
confusion now he's gotta double down and
triple down and he's gotta keep this
fantasy alive because his base loves
this fantasy they love this cosplay of
trump is are still our president and it
was all a lie i know everything like ben
was saying in fact everything we're
being told is a lie in fact what the
news tells us is a lie what the doctors
tell us is a lie everything except this
magical man with orange hair this is the
man who knows all and this is what
happens and they're just regurgitated
this propaganda on a daily basis which i
know jessica knows about because she was
on she's been on both sides of this as
being somebody who took in this
propaganda and accepted it as fact from
the fox news of the world to then being
disparaged by the fox news of the world
and seeing them for what they are but
it's truly very it's twisted and it's
very soviet and north korea and and we
just never really seen anything like
this in the united states of america and
it's just so blatant and in your face
that it's almost comical to a point if
25 to 30 of americans weren't believing
it like if you saw the coverage last
night they were talking about the sri
lankan government and everything
happening over there and they blame the
collapse on the sri lankan government on
the green new deal which isn't even a
thing not even something that was passed
here and would have no impact there
because they just really don't want us
to have environmental policies well i'm
sure hunter biden's laptop will release
a statement soon on that what happened
in sri lanka i'm sure that we'll get
some sort
i mean surely they'll figure out a way
it'll be like the marvel cinematic
universe they'll bring in the laptop
they'll bring they'll bring in all these
little things that they make up and
they'll throw them all together but you
got that you got them
they p buddha judge humiliate them on
their own network and then you have
laura ingraham refusing to actually play
that clip but instead completely changes
the words of what he said and said
buddha just called for violence against
the supreme court when he said the
complete opposite but this is what 25 to
30 of americans are being fed on a daily
basis so the work of the january 6
committee is so important but we don't
even have to reach those people at the
end of the day they are cultists we're
just not going to get through to them
right now the people on that side who
want to break through ultimately they
will break through if if the conditions
are right but we're focusing on the
other portion of americans and we even
just saw since the last poll that came
out i think there's been a seven percent
increase in republicans who view donald
trump as responsible for the january six
attack republicans so don't tell me the
january 6 committee is not working and
is not having an effect and i also want
to remind everybody that people do have
very short attention spans and it's not
always a bad thing i mean we have a lot
going on in our lives we have a lot of
personal issues there's a lot going on
in the world to deal with there's a
million different problems we're facing
every single day but to some people the
january 6
insurrection was distant and far away
and when things get distant and far away
they start to you start to change them
in your mind and especially if you're
consuming a media who is not presenting
them as you should as this was a
domestic terrorist attack and we need
justice now then you could gaslight
yourself almost into thinking oh yeah
that wasn't that bad so being able to
see these images being able to relive it
being able to hear directly from the
people in the room the pats of baloneys
all these people this is why it's so
important the truth is coming out donald
trump knows he can't stop it steve
bannon thought he could stop it he was
laughed out of court yesterday
humiliated steve bannon got a pardon
from trump he will probably most likely
end up in prison anyway i mean how big
of a schmuck could you be at the end of
the day how how horrible of a human
being well i i yeah i know jessica can
talk about steve bannon for hours and
hours and jessica you have to come on my
show to talk about again the tony
michael's podcast to talk about steve
bannon because you have like just um
hours and hours of content but uh i i
just want to point out the the the hat
has appeared
i barely got over last night's tex-mex
version of the midas touch podcast and
here we are here we are well thank you
thank you for joining us ben stick
around because my next guest
thank you thank you brett thank you
jessica for joining us ben stick around
for just one second because i have
someone that i think will have fun um
with you uh here we have a texas paul
and now we have the uh
the the the hat brothers here uh at
texas paul if you're on mute uh we can
we can talk there uh texas fall and mute
there
he's he's still he's still on mute he's
still on mute there you go now
maybe maybe
this is this is what happens i'm telling
you hey you know
ben comes down
we get together we have a few drinks and
next thing you know the sun's coming up
and ben's got a cowboy hat well not it's
not a cowboy hat i was corrected i was
corrected on twitter it is not a cowboy
head um
texas paul i i was corrected to you it
is a sombrero it is not a a cowboy hat
apparently well i'll correct you right
there sir again because this is actually
a sombrero cowboy hats come from
vaqueros in mexico
that's the orig that's the original this
is the copy ah i see i said that's the
real deal cowboy hat right there we are
getting hat facts today ben thanks for
thanks for uh joining us and giving us
that again the
tex-mex version i like it you look good
man you look good we'll we'll talk to
you soon we'll talk to you soon
texas paul um give us your take real
quick on hearing from the oath keepers i
got some more guests i want to bring
here but give us your your take on
hearing from the oath keepers and this
january 6 rider what do you think what
do you think these
these witnesses are going to tell us
today
well the the witness from the oath
keepers was originally he actually left
the oath keepers i believe back in 2017
he's going to be quite open about this
he is he wasn't involved in january 6
he's he
is
you know broken off from the cult he has
and he's going to be pretty
straightforward sip alone i worry about
because
you know this whole
attorney-client privilege deal he worked
out i i don't know how forthcoming he's
going to
be i'm keeping my fingers crossed that
that he does what's right for the
country i am i'm keeping my fingers
crossed
um i will i would like to add though you
know everybody's hit it all the way from
karen to
michael
to
brett all talk and talking about these
uh
these groups
you know the oath keepers
i i follow these groups very closely i
do and i will tell you the oath keepers
are clowns they are they're very very
dangerous clowns it's a bunch of
wannabes a bunch of you know gravy seals
fat asses get out in the woods like you
know want to play soldier [ __ ]
every time i see elmer stewart rhodes i
think about that movie the christmas
story with ralphie you'll shoot your eye
out you know what i mean he he is not a
serious man to me a name that you're
going to start hearing in these hearings
i guarantee you is robert patrick lewis
robert patrick lewis founded the fir one
one a praetorian guard
these
are serious people
these are not jokes these are not
enrique enrique tario the beach
hoodlum from miami
this guy
is special forces right
these people are and they recruit from
swat and special forces
they provide security at q and on
rallies and they're crazy as hell they
are nuts they are straight up queueing
on nuts
uh in fact on january 5th there's a
rally you don't hear about much that was
in dc the day before that was at the
freedom plaza where lewis was speaking
and just blabbering all this crazy
cueing on [ __ ] but i i guarantee you
operationally tactically and we even
have some testimony
uh uh from communications picked up by
the fbi that uh um
that that the praetorian guard had a
sniper in position
to protect
the oath keepers that had their stashes
of weapons
the qrs he was in over he was in
overwatch right protecting them and and
i i know i know that stack is probably
going to be important today the stack
being how they entered the building uh
where the qrf the the stash of weapons
was stored i know those are going to be
big features today but also i think
these witnesses are going to tell us
texas paul
um this witness are going to tell us
what initiated that and i believe these
witnesses are going to tell us that this
tweet here uh initiated uh some of this
planning that took place to make sure
that
that january 6 went over smoothly
for the cheeto dust mobster i'll give
you one more one more minute here to end
and then i've got to go to my next guest
what brett was talking about what i
believe the reason that you're hearing
this from
uh trump today and the tweets that you
keep putting up that are just 100
perfect
is
it's a cult
right it's a cult and the cult always
has to hear
everybody lies to you but me
i'm the truth i'm the one and what's
scary is i've done several videos on
this the entire republican party is
morphing into this cristo fascist
cult
and it's it's it's really really scary
stuff being run out of our churches
and that's what this is all about that
you know he is keeping his cult tight no
matter what we say today we're and like
brett says we keep peeling some off
but that core
is going to believe now everything they
hear today is a lie because their
anointed by god leader
has told them this is a lie well thank
you texas paul i appreciate you joining
us i want to bring in someone who uh who
who has some experience with with the
the christian uh right as it were um uh
ron reagan and i also want to bring in
david bender as well ron how are you how
are you ron
ciao from italy yes yes yes yes
how's how's the wood cutting going i
know we
got that with wood all right great
quarter wood that's a lot of wood that's
a lot of wood david how are you today
i'm just throwing my hat in the ring
yeah i i see i see everyone's uh got
their hats on today this is this is not
a uh sombrero okay good trilby hats okay
just be clear it goes back to the old
world did you forget to wash your hair
today
you know it's it's been that kind of day
i will wash my hair so long as donald
trump's name is spoken aloud so it's
been a long time
so so ron ron
ron what do you make of what texas paul
was talking about here because the oath
keepers and the proud boys they're not
really
part of the christian nationalist
movement as much as they've adopted it
to try to you know
stoke violence in the country it seems i
think a lot of the things that he was
saying are very important uh and that
that in in particular there is a whole
now christian
white nationalist dominionist movement
which is being absorbed into the larger
republican party
which
is anti-democratic and this you know you
listen to doug mastroni in pennsylvania
and
and a bunch of others now and they're
openly talking about not only violence
but really the fact that um
white christian nationalists are the
only people who should be in charge of
anything in our country and everybody
else who doesn't buy into their cult
um has no place in our government no
place in our media no place running
businesses
and uh and they're going to to work hard
to make sure that that comes true and
they're not against using violence as he
pointed out yes you know the oath
keepers and the proud boys these people
who dress up as bumblebees and stuff
yeah they're wannabes and they're clowns
um not that they're not dangerous but
they're clowns
but he mentioned the praetorian guard
and there are others like them who are
serious people who've got real military
training and they mean to put it to use
and those some of those people are still
in the military and still in law
enforcement and they're not leaving
they're going to be embedded there and
these people pose a real danger to our
country well you know uh another group
named uh adam laugh and we've we we saw
that name appear several months ago when
the department of justice was really
tracking down some of the threats that
were made on nuclear power plants some
electrical plants uh around the country
uh that's another neo-nazi type group um
that is you know totally in line with
trumpism as it were so david give us
your attention i i actually have a
question for ron because this is
something that's concerned me for a
while now
uh
we're seeing that possibly uh tony
honorado uh a member of the secret
service who became a political uh
appointee in the trump white house and
then what is now back with the secret
service yeah is it possible
you you experienced the secret service i
i this is something that
has concerned me
with active duty military active duty
law enforcement
and even worse and more dangerously
active duty secret service
that may buy into some of this
how does one address that how do you how
do you find out what people are thinking
in in these uh
active duty roles that they play
that's a very good question and uh
this is a very difficult thing to do you
don't want to be in the position
necessarily of purging people from
government because you think they may
disagree with you politically that's the
sort of thing that donald trump would do
on the other hand i
i can say that if you're in the secret
service or any other branch of
government
and you are a trumpist if you are a stop
the steel person
you are not a fan of our our democracy
anymore you are not defending the
constitution
and as such as
a person like that you ought not to be
in those positions anymore if i was the
head of the secret service i would begin
quietly inquiring about people who were
with the pbd the presidential protective
detail who trump i
my
you know what i've heard is selected
because they were loyalists to him
not the office of the president
and i would begin moving them out or at
least moving them out to distant uh
distant posts maybe in alaska which is
where honorado is now he's moved out
he's not been disengaged but i i think
this is something that you know going
forward and and i i commend to everyone
and i put it up in our chat here but to
everyone listening there's a piece that
greg sargent has in the washington post
about how
uh
this violent movement that we're going
to be talking about today the hearings
we'll be showing
is
a an early warning sign around the world
when you begin to see democracies
falling
what
sergeant's piece does is uh through
experts rachel kleinfelder i think has
written a book about it
talks about exactly that the people who
are
in government the people who are outside
of it but who are willing to use violent
tactics
and this is the fear that the violence
hasn't stopped at all with january 6th
it's going to be going on and obviously
some of the things that
we just saw
the supreme court do
has has
been more
uh incendiary uh than anything in my
memory to polarize the nation
so uh it is it's a concern
at so many levels how do ron you're
absolutely right you can't do purity
tests but i do think and and we heard
this
the oath that you take
is to the constitution not to a person
when james comey walked into that office
and was asked or sat down and said you
know i expect loyalty from you
he meant to a person not the office not
the constitution so this is we've we saw
this play out but we haven't seen it
over it's not over at all donald trump
is the now the symptom he is not the
disease no no that's right and you know
you mentioned mr uh chipoloni which is
the as close as i can come to the actual
italian pronunciation
which is
is no cure here mr chipoloni is a bad
guy
uh he has seen it in his own best
interest i suspect because he doesn't
want to lose his law license to
cooperate to some extent with the uh
with the committee mr chipoloni claiming
attorney-client privilege who was his
client not mr trump the white house the
executive branch and that means us
so he's got that all wrong um and i'm
surprised they let him get away with
that but i think they really wanted to
hear what he had to say about certain
things and were willing to to play ball
with him to a certain extent um but
you know you mentioned the supreme court
um we've got three branches of
government we've got the judiciary we've
got the legislative and we have the
executive and then we have a fourth
estate which is of course the price the
media
but uh the judiciary branch is already
gone
it is now utterly corrupt and without
any legitimacy
six religious fanatics
on the on the supreme court are going to
do whatever they want to do
uh there they've pretty much announced
that
uh the legislative branch the senate of
course is
profoundly undemocratic the way it's
constituted and uh and can get nothing
done
if democrats lose the house
in november and the entire legislative
branch then is effectively under the
control of republicans well that just
leaves the executive
and what happens in 2024 if that falls
to the republicans too
the people that we're worried about here
the people who have uh
who have enabled violence let's say will
now be in charge of our government and
our government as we like to think of it
as a republican democracy small our
republican democracy will cease to exist
uh uh i think i think you make a a good
point there that there's a lot at stake
with these hearings as we watch uh the
hearing room here the witnesses have not
come in yet um david i'll give you a
chance i want to bring in my executive
producer and co-host uh gabe sanchez hey
gabe
hey there gabe
so the the only
little ring of sunshine i like to i like
to do that uh the you know
rachel used to call me pollyanna
uh
but
you know there is a chance wrong
if on the flip side of this if
the senate expands outside of the
mansion cinema blockade
and you get enough votes to overturn the
filibuster
and if this is a wave election not the
way we see it but roe and these hearings
affect democratic turnout on a level
that may be unprecedented because people
are genuinely angry about what's
happening it's not simmering down at all
it won't by october november we hold the
house
we have a filibuster uh proof senate
the bill number one
is to
make the court
what it was when it became nine justices
that was to that was in parallel to the
number of circuit courts we had
you know 150 years ago there were nine
circuit courts nine supreme court
justices and how many we have now
wait for it thirteen
uh counting the federal court of appeals
thirteen appellate uh
courts which allows for
four more justices
that
is a game changer
and that is not packing the court that
is making the court equal to the
workload and the burden uh that is what
brought it to nine or when it was
changed
so
that's me being pollyanna
i am
we all know that
but it's important to say that there is
some hope and there's a reason for
people to not give up and to be prepared
to vote in numbers like no one has ever
seen before
and november
you know one other thing that strikes me
about this and i felt the same way about
the mueller report uh you know when it
came out and before it came out is we
all know what happened
here on january 6th and before and after
we know what the story is it's great
that they're laying it out for an
american public that doesn't maybe pay
quite as much attention as we do it's
great that they're laying that out for
the justice department in case they
really want to pursue
legal cases against everybody including
uh mr trump but we all know
what happened here a sitting president
tried to interfere with the peaceful
transfer of power tried to overthrow the
government basically this has never
happened before and it's an
extraordinary event and there it is it's
right in front of us
there's no question about this anymore
and there never was but we have to ask
ourselves now what are we really doing
about this as an american public why did
we let this man get into the white house
in the first place well the public
didn't because of course they voted him
you know by three million votes they
they gave it to hillary clinton but we
have an electoral college what are we
going to do about that bill
um you know what is wrong with us and
what is wrong with the media that
allowed that to happen that didn't
report honestly on who donald trump was
from the very beginning and point out to
the public that it's unacceptable that
somebody like this should end up in the
white house
what how are they gonna handle these
hearings are they gonna are they gonna
tell us honestly tell
the public honestly what the danger
really is and how severe it is and how
imminent that danger is i hope so
some some are doing a good job but
they're stirring with the big paddle as
usual
well you know a lot of people gave a lot
of criticism to a certain someone who is
on
nbc on on sundays when he made the
statement about uh that it would be bad
for the country if donald trump would um
face prosecution which i think
a big majority of the country did not
appreciate that statement because i
think the
what you're to what you guys are saying
about the supreme court all the branches
of government uh how we have elections
in this country i believe actually a
prosecution of donald trump is exactly
what our country needs at this point and
i think that's what the january 6 select
committee is trying to do in the in the
court of public opinion because there is
going to be criminal courts here we've
seen the criminal courts but the report
of public opinion is the one that i
think that they're operating in with the
january 6 select company gabe do you
have a question for our guest here no i
just wanted to add on to what ron was
saying i think that you make a very good
point it's i mean like you look at kind
of what's happening right we have a coup
in plain sight we literally watch this
happen in real time like the [ __ ]
hitting the fan uh you know with the
mueller report it was more behind the
scenes and then there was kind of you
know it wasn't until the report was
released and kind of what their findings
were and then at that point people could
dismiss and say oh this wasn't really a
thing or uh you know it was fake news or
was a hoax
uh this is different right and also
we are literally watching this again in
real time
with the findings to say we have people
coming forward we have depositions
witness you know witnesses testifying
under oath we've got documentation
evidence
uh from here to kingdom come kind of
right now because it keeps coming
and thanks to people like cassidy
hutchinson it allows us to see more
people willing to come forward and and
do what you know
more or less their kind of
their right is or or just their
responsibility as someone who is part of
the administration who at that time
kind of let it happen but now whether
through
peer pressure or uh
having an epiphany or what have you are
now willing to say okay
we can't let something like this happen
again and i at least want to be someone
who puts themselves forward in history
as
you know as a person who who is willing
to who is uh willing to
you know defend democracy defend the
constitution uh uh
at least be known as someone who is
willing to say something as opposed to
someone who
uh was gonna be you know dragged through
the mud of history as someone who just
stood by is complacent right
um that's what's
here yeah
our country is at stake here
the republicans cannot be allowed to
take power again they cannot be allowed
to do that and we're the only people
that can stop that from happening if
they take power again we don't have a
democracy anymore and they've made that
very plain exactly they're not hiding
that fact anymore uh so so you like maya
angelou i think it was said when
somebody tells you who they are believe
them well they're telling us who they
are believe
and at the moment i think the committee
is about to tell us who they are am i
correct uh it looks like they're taking
the the stage here so i'll uh what
chairman thompson thank you very much uh
we'll we'll get back to our guest soon
thank you ron thank you david thanks
gabe you bet thanks
it appears select committed investigate
the january 6 attack on the united
states capitol will be in order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee in
recess
at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material
presented during today's hearing
good afternoon
when i think about the most basic way to
explain the importance of elections in
the united states
there's a phrase that always comes to
mind
it may sound straightforward but it's
meaningful
we settle our differences at the ballot
box
sometimes my
choice prevails
sometimes yours does
but it's that simple
we cast our votes we count the votes if
something seems off with the results
we can challenge them in court
and then we accept the results
when you're on the losing side that
doesn't mean you have to
be happy about it
and in the united states there's plenty
you can do
and say so
you can protest you can organize
you can get ready for the next election
to try to make sure your side has a
better chance the next time
the people sell their differences at the
ballot box
but you can't turn violent
you can't try to achieve your desired
outcome through force or harassment or
intimidation
any real leader who sees their
supporters going down that path
approaching that line
has a responsibility to say
stop
we gave it our best
we came up short
we try again next time
because we settle
our differences at the ballot box
on december 14 2020 the presidential
election was officially over
the electoral college had cast this vote
joe biden was the president-elect of the
united states
by that point many of donald trump's
supporters were already convinced that
the election had been stolen
because that's what donald trump had
been telling them
so what donald trump was required to do
in that moment
what would have been required of any
american leader was to say
we did our best and we came up short
he went the opposite way
he seized on the anger he had already
stoked among his most loyal supporters
and as they approached the line
he didn't wave them off he urged them on
today
the committee will explain how as a part
of his last ditch effort to overturn the
election and block the transfer of power
donald trump summoned a mob to
washington d.c
and ultimately spurred that mob to wage
a violent attack on our democracy
our colleagues ms murphy of florida and
mr raskin of maryland will lay out their
story
first i'm pleased to recognize our
distinguished vice chair ms chaney of
wyoming for any opening comments she'd
care to offer
thank you very much mr chairman
our committee did not conduct a hearing
last week but we did conduct an on the
record interview of president trump's
former white house counsel pat sipoloni
if you have watched these hearings
you've heard us call for mr sipoloni to
come forward to testify he did
and mr sipoloni's testimony met our
expectations
we will save for our next hearing
president trump's behavior during the
violence of january 6.
today's hearing will take us from
december 14th 2020 when the electoral
college met and certified the results of
the 2020 presidential election
up through the morning of january 6th
you will see certain segments of pat
sipoloni's testimony today
we will also see today how president
trump summoned a mob to washington and
how the president's stolen election lies
provoked that mob to attack the capital
and we will hear from a man who was
induced by president trump's lies to
come to washington and join the mob
and how that decision has changed his
life
today's hearing is our seventh we have
covered significant ground over the past
several weeks
and we have also seen a change in how
witnesses and lawyers in the trump orbit
approach this committee
initially their strategy in some cases
appeared to be to deny and delay
today there appears to be a general
recognition that the committee has
established key facts
including that virtually everyone close
to president trump
his justice department officials his
white house advisers his white house
counsel his campaign
all told him the 2020 election was not
stolen
this appears to have changed the
strategy for defending donald trump
now the argument seems to be that
president trump was manipulated by
others outside the administration
that he was persuaded to ignore his
closest advisors
and that he was incapable of telling
right from wrong
this new strategy is to try to blame
only john eastman or sydney powell or
congressman scott perry or others and
not president trump
in this version the president was quote
poorly served by these outside advisors
the strategy is to blame people his
advisors called quote the crazies for
what donald trump did
this of course is nonsense
president trump is a 76 year old man
he is not an impressionable child
just like everyone else in our country
he is responsible for his own actions
and his own choices
as our investigation has shown
donald trump had access to more detailed
and specific information showing that
the election was not actually stolen
than almost any other american and he
was told this over and over again
no rational or sane man in his position
could disregard that information and
reach the opposite conclusion
and donald trump cannot escape
responsibility by being willfully blind
nor can any argument of any kind excuse
president trump's behavior during the
violent attack on january 6th
as you watch our hearing today i would
urge you to keep your eye on two
specific points
first you will see evidence that trump's
legal team led by rudy giuliani knew
that they lacked actual evidence of
widespread fraud sufficient to prove
that the election was actually stolen
they knew it
but they went ahead with january 6th
anyway
and second consider how millions of
americans were persuaded to believe what
donald trump's closest advisors in his
administration did not
these americans did not have access to
the truth like donald trump did
they put their faith and their trust in
donald trump
they wanted to believe in him they
wanted to fight for their country and he
deceived them
for millions of americans that may be
painful to accept but it is true
thank you mr chairman i yield back
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentlewoman from florida miss murphy
and a gentleman from maryland mr raskin
for opening statements
thank you mr chairman
we know beyond a shadow of a doubt that
then president donald trump lost in a
free and fair election
and yet president trump insisted that
his loss was due to fraud in the
election process rather than to the
democratic will of the voters
the president continued to make this
claim despite being told again and again
by the courts by the justice department
by his campaign officials and by some of
his closest advisers that the evidence
did not support this assertion
this was the big lie and millions of
americans were deceived by it
too many of our fellow citizens still
believe it to this day
it's corrosive to our country and
damaging to our democracy
as our committee has shown in prior
hearings
following the election president trump
relentlessly pursued multiple
interlocking lines of effort all with a
single goal
to remain in power despite having lost
the lines of effort were aimed at his
loyal vice president mike pence
at state election and elected officials
and at the u.s department of justice
the president pressured the vice
president to obstruct the process to
certify the election result he demanded
that state officials find him enough
votes to overturn the election outcome
in that state and he pressed the
department of justice to find widespread
evidence of fraud
when justice officials told the
president that such evidence did not
exist
the president urged them to simply
declare that the election was corrupt
on december 14th the electoral college
met to officially confirm that joe biden
would be the next president
the evidence shows that once this
occurred president trump and those who
were willing to aid and abet him
turned their attention to the joint
session of congress scheduled for
january 6 at which the vice president
would preside
in their warped view this ceremonial
event was the next and perhaps the last
inflection point that could be used to
reverse the outcome of the election
before mr biden's inauguration
as president trump put it the vice
president and enough members of congress
simply needed to summon the courage to
act to help them find that courage the
president called for backup
early in the morning of december 19 the
president sent out a tweet urging his
followers to travel to washington dc for
january 6.
be there we'll be wild the president
wrote
as my colleague mr raskin will describe
in detail this tweet served as a call to
action and in some cases as a call to
arms for many of president trump's most
loyal supporters
it's clear the president intended the
assembled crowd on
the january 6 to serve his goal
and as you've already seen and as you
will see again today some of those who
were coming had specific plans
the president's goal was to stay in
power for a second term despite losing
the election
the assembled crowd was one of the tools
to achieve that goal
and in today's hearing we will focus on
events that took place in the final
weeks leading up to january 6
starting in mid-december and will add
color and context to evidence you've
already heard about
and will also provide additional new
evidence
for example you'll hear about meetings
in which the president entertained
extreme measures designed to help him
stay in power like the seizure of voting
machines
we will show some of the coordination
that occurred between the white house
and members of congress as it relates to
january 6
and some of these members of congress
would later seek pardons
we will also examine some of the
planning for the january 6 protests
placing special emphasis on one rally
planner's concerns about the potential
violence
and we will describe some of the
president's key actions on the evening
of january 5th and the morning of
january 6 including how the president
edited and ad-libbed his speech that
morning at the ellipse directed the
crowd to march to the capitol and spoke
off-script in a way that further
inflamed an already angry crowd
i yield to the gentleman from maryland
mr raskin thank you ms murphy mr
chairman madam vice chair
four days after the electors met across
the country and made joe biden the
president-elect donald trump was still
trying to find a way to hang on to the
presidency
on friday december 18th his team of
outside advisors paid him a surprise
visit in the white house that would
quickly become the stuff of legend the
meeting has been called unhinged not
normal in the craziest meeting of the
trump presidency
the outside lawyers who'd been involved
in dozens of failed lawsuits had lots of
theories supporting the big lie but no
evidence to support it
as we will see however they brought to
the white house a draft executive order
that they had prepared for president
trump to further his ends specifically
they proposed the immediate mass seizure
of state election machines by the u.s
military the meeting ended after
midnight with apparent rejection of that
idea in the wee hours of december 19th
dissatisfied with his options
donald trump decided to call for a large
and wild crowd on wednesday january 6th
the day when congress would meet to
certify the electoral votes
never before in american history had a
president called for a crowd to come
contest the counting of electoral votes
by congress or engaged in any effort
designed to influence delay or obstruct
the joint session of congress in doing
its work required by our constitution in
the electoral count act
as we'll see donald trump's 142 am tweet
electrified and galvanized his
supporters especially the dangerous
extremists and the oath keepers the
proud boys and other racist and white
nationalist groups spoiling for a fight
against the government
three rings of interwoven attack were
now operating towards january 6. on the
inside ring trump continued trying to
work to overturn the election by getting
mike pence to abandon his oath of office
as vice president and assert the
unilateral power to reject electoral
votes
this would have been a fundamental and
unprecedented breach
of the constitution that would promise
trump multiple ways
of staying in office
meanwhile in the middle ring members of
domestic violent extremist groups
created an alliance both online and in
person to coordinate a massive effort to
storm invade and occupy the capital
by placing a target on the joint session
of congress trump had mobilized these
groups around a common goal
emboldening them strengthening their
working relationships and helping build
their numbers
finally in the outer ring on january 6th
there assembled a large and angry crowd
the political force that trump
considered both the touchstone and the
measure of his political power here were
thousands of enraged trump followers
thoroughly convinced by the big lie who
traveled from across the country to join
trump's wild rally to stop the steel
with the proper incitement by political
leaders
and the proper instigation from the
extremists
many members of this crowd could be led
to storm the capital
confront the vice president in congress
and try to overturn the 2020 election
results
all of these efforts would converge and
explode on january the 6th
mr chairman as you know better than any
other member of this committee from the
wrenching struggle for voting rights in
your beloved mississippi
the problem of politicians whipping up
mob violence to destroy fair elections
is the oldest domestic enemy of
constitutional democracy in america
abraham lincoln knew it too
in 1837 a racist mob in alton illinois
broke into the offices of an
abolitionist newspaper and killed its
editor elijah lovejoy
lincoln wrote a speech in which he said
that no transatlantic military giant
could ever
crush us as a nation even with all of
the fortunes in the world
but if downfall ever comes to america he
said
we ourselves would be its author
and finisher
if racist mobs are encouraged by
politicians to rampage and terrorize
lincoln said they will violate the
rights of other citizens and quickly
destroy the bonds of social trust
necessary for democracy to work mobs and
demagogues will put us on a path to
political tyranny lincoln said
as we'll see today this very old problem
has returned with new ferocity today as
a president who lost an election
deployed a mob which included dangerous
extremists to attack the constitutional
system of election in the peaceful
transfer of power and as we'll see the
creation of the internet and social
media has given today's tyrants tools of
propaganda and disinformation that
yesterday's despots could only have
dreamed of
i yield back to the gentle lady from
florida miss murphy
article two of the united states
constitution establishes the electoral
college
each state's laws provide that electors
are to be chosen by a popular vote
and on december 14 2020 electors met in
all 50 states and the district of
columbia to cast their votes
joseph biden won by a margin of 306 to
232
the election was over
mr biden was the president-elect
before the electoral college met donald
trump and his allies filed dozens of
legal challenges to the election but
they lost over and over again including
in front of multiple judges president
trump had nominated to the bench
in many of these cases the judges were
highly critical of the arguments put
forward explaining that no genuine
evidence of widespread fraud had been
presented for example a federal judge in
pennsylvania said
this court has been presented with
strained legal arguments without merited
merit and speculative accusations
unsupported by evidence
in the united states of america this
cannot justify the disenfranchisement of
a single voter let alone all the voters
of its sixth most populated state
on december 15th after the electoral
college certified the outcome the
republican majority leader in the senate
acknowledged mr biden's victory
yesterday electors met in all 50 states
so as of this morning our country has
officially
a president-elect
and a vice president-elect
many millions of us had hoped the
presidential election
would yield
a different result
but our system of government has
processes to determine who will be sworn
in
on january the 20th
the electoral college
has spoken
so today i want to congratulate
president-elect joe biden
even members of president trump's
cabinet and his white house staff
understood the significance of his
losses in the courts in the absence of
evidence of fraud they also respected
the constitutional certification by the
electoral college many of them told
president trump that it was time to
concede the election to mr biden for
example then secretary of labor gene
scalia an accomplished lawyer in the son
of late justice scalia called president
trump in mid-december and advised him to
concede and accept the rulings of the
courts
and so i had to put a call into the
president i might have called on the
13th we spoke i believe on the 14th
in which um i conveyed to him that i uh
thought that
it was time for him to acknowledge that
president biden had
prevailed in the election
but i communicated to the president that
when that legal process is exhausted
and
when the electors are have voted
that
that's the point of which that outcome
needs to be expected i told him that i
did believe yes that once the those
legal processes were run
uh if fraud had not been established
that had affected the outcome of the
election then unfortunately i believe
that what had to be done was conceive
the outcome
as you've seen in prior hearings
president trump's justice department his
white house staff and his campaign
officials were repeatedly telling him
that there was no evidence of fraud
sufficient to change the outcome of the
election
and last week we conducted an eight-hour
interview with president trump's white
house counsel pat cipolloni you'll see a
number of excerpts of that interview
today and even more in our next hearing
mr sipoloni told us that he agreed with
the testimony that there was no evidence
of fraud sufficient to overturn the
election
i want to start by asking if you agree
with mr zimbani with the conclusions of
matt morgan and bill barr of all of the
individuals who evaluate those clinics
there's no evidence of election
sufficient to undermine the outcome in
particular
yes i agree with that
and mr sivaloni also specifically
testified that he believed that donald
trump should have conceded the election
did you believe that and mr sibling that
the president should concede once you
made the determination based on the
investigations that you credited doj did
did you in your mind form a belief that
the president should concede the
election loss
at a certain point after the election
well again
i was the white house counsel
some of those decisions are political
so to the extent that
but but if your question is that i
believe he should
concede the election
at a point in time yes i did i i believe
um
leader mcconnell went on to the floor of
the senate i believe in mid-december and
basically said you know the process is
done you know
that would be in line with
my thinking on these things
as attorney general bill barr testified
december 14th should have been the end
of the matter
december 14th
was the day that the state certified
their votes and sent them to congress
and
in my view that was
the end of the matter uh i didn't see
uh
you know i thought that
this would lead inexorably to a new
administration
mr sipoloni also testified that the
president's chief of staff mark meadows
said he shared this view
as early as that november 23rd meeting
we understand that there was discussion
about the president possibly conceding
the election and specifically
we understand that
mark meadows assured both you and
attorney general barr that the president
would eventually agree to a graceful
exit do you remember mr meadows making
any such representation are you saying
as part of that meeting or separately
again without without getting into that
meeting i would say that that is a that
is a statement and a sentiment that i
heard from
mark maddox i see and again do you know
if it was on november 23rd at some point
again i i it was probably
you know
around that time and it was probably
subsequent to that time it wasn't a one
time
statement
mr meadows has refused to testify and
the committee is in litigation with him
but many other white house officials
shared the view that once the litigation
ended and the electoral college met the
election was over and here's president
trump's former press secretary
i wanted to clarify uh ms mcinerney so
back to my previous question it was your
view then
or was it your view that the efforts to
overturn the election should have
stopped once the litigation was complete
in my view upon the conclusion of
litigation was when i began to plan for
life after the administration
and this is what ivanka trump told us
december 14th was the day on which the
electoral college met when these
electors around the country met and
cast the electoral votes consistent with
the the popular vote in each state and
and it was obviously a public proceeding
or a series of proceedings
that
president biden had obtained the
requisite number of electors was that an
important day for you did that affect
sort of your planning or your
realization
as to whether or not there was going to
be an end of this administration
i think so i think it was my
my sentiment probably prior as well
judd dear was a white house deputy press
secretary
this was his testimony about what he
told president trump
i told him that my personal viewpoint
was that the electoral college had met
which is the
system that our country is is set under
to elect a president and vice president
and i believed at that point that the
means for him to pursue
uh litigation
was probably closed
and you recall what his response if any
was he disagreed
we've also seen this testimony from
attorney general barr reflecting a view
of the white house staff in late
november 2020
and then at that point i left and as i
walked out of the oval office jared was
there with dan scavino who ran his
ran the president's um social media and
who i thought was a reasonable
guy and believe is a reasonable guy and
i said
how long is how long is he going to
carry on with this stolen election stuff
where is this going to go
and by that time
meadows had caught up with me
and uh leaving the office and caught up
to me and and said uh
that uh
he said look i i think
uh that he's becoming more
realistic and knows that there's a limit
to how far he can take this and then
jared said you know yeah we're working
on this we're working on it
likewise in this testimony cassidy
hutchinson an aide to mark meadows
described her conversations with
president trump's director of national
intelligence john ratcliffe a former
republican congressman
he
had expressed say that he was concerned
that it could spiral out of control
and
potentially
be dangerous
either
for our democracy or
the way that things were going for the
sex
of course underlying all of this is the
fundamental principle that the president
of the united states cannot simply
disregard the rulings of state and
federal courts which are empowered to
address specific election-related claims
the president cannot simply pretend that
the courts had not ruled
by that time
the president or his associates had
brought had lost 60 out of 61 cases uh
uh
that they had brought to challenge uh
different aspects of
uh
the election in a number of states they
lost 60 out of 61 of those cases
um so by the time we get to january 3rd
that that's
that's been clear
i assume pat that you would agree the
president is is
obligated to abide by the rulings of the
courts
of course
and and i assume you also everybody
everybody is obligated to abide by rules
of course
and i assume you also would agree the
president has a particular obligation to
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed
that is one of the president's
obligations correct
yet president trump disregarded these
court rulings and the council from his
closest advisers and continued his
efforts to cling to power
in our prior hearings you have heard
considerable testimony about president
trump's attempts to corruptly pressure
vice president pence to refuse to count
elect electoral votes to corrupt the
department of justice to pressure state
officials and state legislatures and to
create and submit a series of fake
electoral slates
now we will show you what other actions
president trump was taking between
december 14th 2020 and january 6. i
yield to the gentleman from maryland mr
askin thank you ms murphy
throughout our hearings you've heard how
president trump made baseless claims
that voting machines were being
manipulated by foreign powers in the
2020 election
you've also heard trump's attorney
general bill barr describe such claims
as complete nonsense which he told the
president let's review that testimony
i saw absolutely zero basis for the
allegations
but they were made in such a sensational
way
that they obviously were influencing a
lot of people
members of the public
that there was this systemic
corruption in the system and that their
votes didn't count and that these
machines controlled by somebody else
were actually determining it which was
complete nonsense
and it was being laid out there and i
told them that it was it was uh
crazy stuff and they were wasting their
time on that
and i was doing a great grave disservice
to the country
we've learned that president trump's
white house counsel
agreed with the department of justice
about
attorney this barr made a public
announcement on december first less than
a month after the election that he had
seen
no suspended frogs fishing them
bears say that by december 1st you could
reach the city it's fair to say that i
agree with attorney general's bar
attorney general barr's conclusion on
december 1st
yes i did and i supported that
conclusion
however
the strong rejection of the attorney
general and the white house counsel
these claims did not stop the president
from trying to press them in public but
that's not all they did indeed as you'll
see in this clip the president asked
attorney general bill barr to have the
department of justice seize voting
machines in the states
my recollection is the president said
something like
uh
well we could get to the bot you know
some people say we could get to the
bottom of this if if the department sees
the machines
it was a typical way of raising a point
and
i said absolutely not there's no
probable cause and i'm not going to
seize any machines
and that was that yeah
but this wasn't the end of the matter on
the evening of december 18 2020 sydney
powell general michael flynn and others
entered the white house for an unplanned
meeting with the president the meeting
that would last multiple hours and
become hot-blooded and contentious
the executive order behind me on the
screen
was drafted on december the 16th just
two days after the electoral college
vote by several of the president's
outside advisors over a luncheon at the
trump international hotel
as you can see here this proposed order
directs the secretary of defense to
seize voting machines quote effective
immediately but it goes even further
than that
under the order
president trump would appoint
a special counsel
with the power to seize machines and
then charge people with crimes with all
resources necessary to carry out her
duties
the specific plan was to name sidney
powell as special counsel the trump
lawyer who had spent the post-election
period making outlandish claims about
venezuelan and chinese interference in
the election among others here's what
white house counsel pat sipoloni had to
say about sidney powell's qualifications
to take on such expansive authority
i don't think cindy powell would say
that
i thought it was a good idea to appoint
her special counsel i was being a little
quote i didn't think she should have
been appointed to anything
sidney powell told the president that
these steps were justified because of
her evidence of foreign interference in
the 2020 election however as we've seen
trump's allies had no such evidence and
of course no legal authority for the
federal government to seize state voting
machines here's mr sipoloni again
denouncing sydney powell's terrible idea
there was a real question in my mind and
a real concern
you know particularly after the attorney
general had reached the conclusion
that there was a sufficient election
fraud to change the outcome of the
election
when
other people kept suggesting
that
there was
the answer is what is it
and at some point you have to put up or
shut up
that was my view why was this a broader
scale
a bad idea for the country
to have the federal government sees
voting machines
it's a terrible idea for the country
that's not how we do things in the
united states
there's no legal authority to do that
and
there is a way to contest elections
you know that
that happens all the time
but the idea that the federal government
could come in and
seize election machines
you know that
that's i don't i don't understand why we
even have to tell you why that's a bad
idea
it's a terrible idea
for all of its absurdity the december
18th meeting was critically important
because president trump got to watch up
close for several hours as his white
house counsel and other white house
lawyers destroyed the baseless factual
claims and ridiculous legal arguments
being offered by sidney powell mike
flynn and others president trump now
knew all these claims were nonsense
not just from his able white house
lawyers but also from his own department
of justice officials and indeed his own
campaign officials as white house
counsel pat cipollone told us
with respect to the whole election fraud
issue
that to me is sort of if you're going to
make those kind of claims
and people were open to them early on
because people were making all sorts of
claims and the real question is
show the others
okay
it wasn't just the justice department
the trump campaign and the trump white
house lawyers who knew it even rudy
giuliani's own legal team admitted that
they did not have any real evidence of
fraud sufficient to change the election
result
here's an email from
rudy giuliani's lead investigator bernie
carrick
on december 28 2020 to chief of staff
mark meadows mr carrick did not mince
any words we can do all the
investigations we want later but if the
president plans on winning it's the
legislators that have to be moved and
this will do just that mr carrick wanted
the president to win what he didn't say
in this email was what he would later
tell the select committee in a letter
that his lawyer wrote to us in november
the letter said quote
it was impossible for mr carrick and his
team to determine conclusively whether
there was widespread fraud or whether
that widespread fraud would have altered
the outcome of the election in other
words
even rudy giuliani's own legal team knew
before january 6 that they hadn't
collected
enough actual evidence to support any of
their stolen election claims here's what
trump campaign senior adviser jason
miller told the committee about some of
the so-called evidence of fraud that the
campaign had seen from the giuliani team
so do you know what the examples of
fraud numbers names and supporting
evidence was that
you sent to mo brooks's office and i say
you i mean you are the campaign
there are some
very very
general
uh documents as far as
as far as say for example here the
handful of dead people in several
different states
um here are
uh explanations on a couple of the legal
challenges as far as that saying that
the
um the rules were changed in an
unconstitutional manner uh but it was to
say that it was
thin uh is probably an understatement
here's how president trump's deputy
campaign manager described the evidence
of fraud that the campaign had seen
you never came to
learn or understand that mayor giuliani
had
had produced evidence of election fraud
is that fair
that's fair
and here's testimony that we received
from the speaker of the arizona house of
representatives rusty bowers about an
exchange that he had with rudy giuliani
after the election
at some point did one of them
make a comment that
they didn't have evidence but they had a
lot of theories
that was mr giuliani
chief of staff mark meadows told people
that he thought trump should concede
around the time the electoral college
certified the result but nonetheless he
later worked to try to facilitate
president trump's wishes
here's what cassidy hutchinson told us
during this period
he um
i perceived his goal with all this
to keep trump in office
um
you know he had
very
seriously and deeply considered
the allegations of voter fraud
but when he began acknowledging that
maybe there wasn't enough voter fraud
to overturn the election you know i
witnessed him
start to explore potential
constitutional loopholes
extensively
which are then connected with john
eastman's theories
the startling conclusion is this
even an agreed upon complete lack of
evidence could not stop president trump
mark meadows and their allies from
trying to overturn
the results of a free and fair election
so let's return to that meeting at the
white house on the evening of december
18. that night a group showed up at the
white house including sydney powell
retired lieutenant general michael flynn
and former overstock.com ceo patrick
byrne
after gaining access to the building
from a junior white house staffer the
group made their way to the oval office
they were able to speak with the
president by himself for some time until
white house officials learned of the
meeting
what ensued was a heated and profane
clash between this group and president
trump's white house advisers who traded
personal insults
accusations of disloyalty to the
president and even challenges to
physically fight
the meeting would last over six hours
beginning here in the oval office
moving around the west wing and many
hours later ending up in the president's
private residence
the select committee has spoken with six
of the participants as well as staffers
who could hear the screaming from
outside the oval office
what took place next
is best told in their own words as you
will see from this video
do you believe that it was going to work
that you're going to be able to get to
see the president uh without an
appointment
i had no idea
uh in fact you did get to see the
president without an appointment we did
how much time did you have along with
the president i say alone you had other
people with you but right from his aides
before
the crowd came running uh probably no
more than 10 or 15 minutes
was in that i bet that's the baloney set
a new land speed record i got a call
either from
molly
but i need to get to the oval office so
that was the first point that i had
recognized
okay there was nobody in there from the
white house mark's gone
what's going on right now i opened the
door
and i walked in
i saw general flynn
i saw sidney powell sitting there
i was not happy to see the people
in the oval office
well again i don't think they were
providing well first of all
the overstock person i i've never never
thought who this guy was
actually the first thing i did i walked
in i looked at him and i said who were
you
and he told me i don't think i don't
think any of these people were providing
the president with good advice
and
so i didn't understand how they had
gotten in
in the short period of time that you had
with the president did
he seem receptive to the presentation
that you were making
he was very interested in hearing
particularly about the fifa funding
and the terms of one three eight four
eight that apparently nobody else had
bothered to inform him of
i was asking i'd like you to claim that
the democrats were working with yugoslav
as venezuelans and whomever else and at
one point
uh general flynn took out a
diagram that supposedly showed
i pee addresses all over the world
and
peter who was who was communicating with
whom via the machines and some comment
about like nest thermostats being hooked
up to the internet
so it's been reported that during this
meeting ms powell talked about dominion
voting machines and made various
election fraud claims that involve
foreign countries such as venezuela
iran
and china is that accurate
was it meeting tense
oh yeah
[Music]
i it was not a casual meeting
explain
i mean at times there were people
shouting at each other
throwing insults at each other
um
it wasn't just sort of people sitting
around on the couch like
chit-chatting do you recall whether he
raised to miss powell the fact that she
and the campaign had lost all of the 60
cases that they had brought in
litigation
yes he raised that and what was the
response
i don't remember
what she said i don't think it was a
good response sipilonian hirschmann and
whoever the other guy was
showed nothing but
contempt and disdain
of the president and
the three of them were really sort of
forcefully
attacking
me
verbally
um
eric
derek and we were pushing back and we
were asking one simple question
as a general matter
where is the evidence
so what response did you get when you
asked his pal and her colleagues where's
a variety of responses based on my
current recollection including you know
i can't believe you would say something
you know things like this like what do
you mean where's the evidence you should
know yeah
things like that or
you know
a disregard i would say a general
disregard for the importance of actually
backing up say with facts
and you know then there was discussion
of well you know we don't have it now
but we will have it or whatever
i mean if if it had been me sitting in
his chair i would have fired all of them
that night and had him escorted out of
the building it's debra and i both
challenged what she was saying
and
she says well the judges are corrupt and
i was like everyone
every single case that you've done in
the country you guys lost every one of
them is corrupt even the ones we
appointed
and
i'm being nice that was much more harsh
to her so one of the other things that's
been reported that was said during this
meeting was that president trump told
white house lawyers mr hirschman and mr
sipoloni that they weren't offering him
any solutions but miss powell and others
were so why not try
what miss powell and others were
proposing do you remember anything along
those lines being said by president
trump
i do that sounds right
i think that it got to the point where
the screaming was
completely
completely
out there i mean you got people walking
it was late at night it had been a long
day and
what they were proposing
i thought was
nuts gonna i'm gonna categorically
describe it as
you guys are not tough enough
or maybe i put it another way you're a
bunch of [ __ ]
excuse the expression but that's i
i'm almost certain the word was used
flynn screamed at me that i was a
quitter and everything kept on standing
up and turning around and screaming at
me
and then at a certain point i had it
with him
so
i yelled back
either come over
or sit your ref and ass back down the
president and the white house team
went upstairs
to the residents
but to the uh
public part of the residency the big the
big parlor where you can have meetings
in the conference room
they call it the yellow oval
yes exactly the yellow overalls
i always called it the upper um
and i'm not exactly sure where the
sydney group went i think maybe the
roosevelt room
and i stayed in the cabinet room which
is kind of cool i really like that
all by myself
at the end of the day
we landed where we started the meeting
at least from a
structural standpoint which was
sydney powell
was fighting
mike flynn was fighting they were
looking for avenues that would
enable
that would result in
president trump remaining
president trump for a second term
the meeting finally ended after midnight
here are text messages sent by cassidy
hutchinson during and after the meeting
as you can see ms hutchinson reported
that the meeting in the west wing was
unhinged
the meeting finally broke up after
midnight
during the early
morning of december 19
cassidy hutchinson captured the moment
of mark meadows escorting rudy giuliani
off the white house grounds to quote
make sure he didn't wander back into the
mansion
certain accounts of this meeting
indicate that president trump actually
granted ms powell's security clearance
and appointed her to a somewhat
ill-defined position of special counsel
he asked pat cipolloni if he had the
authority
to name me special counsel and he said
yes
and then he asked him if he had the
authority to give me whatever security
clearance i needed and pat stipple and
he said yes
and then the president said okay you
know i'm naming her that and i'm giving
her a security clearance and then
shortly before we left and it totally
blew up was when uh sipullonia and or
hershman and whoever the other young man
was
said you can name her whatever
you want to name her and no one's going
to pay any attention to it
how did he respond how did the president
respond to that
uh something like you see what i deal
with i deal with this all the time
over the ensuing days no further steps
were taken to appoint sidney powell but
there is some ambiguity about what the
president actually said and did during
the meeting
here is how pat sipoloni described
it i don't know what her
understanding of
whether she had been appointed what she
had been appointed to
okay in my view she hadn't been
appointed to anything
and ultimately wasn't afforded to
anything because there had to be other
steps taken so that was my view when i
left the meeting but she may have a
different view and others may have a
different view and the president
were any steps taken including the
president himself
telling her she'd been appointed
again i'm not going to get into what the
president said in the meeting uh yeah my
recollection is
you're not appointed even you're not
appointed until till steps are taken to
get the paperwork done get and when i
left the meeting
okay
i guess i guess what i'm trying to say
is
i'm not going to get into what the
president said
or what who said he wanted mr uh mr
ballen
when um
the matter continued to flare up over
the next several days was it your
understanding that cindy powell was
still seeking an appointment or that she
was asserting that she had been
appointed by the president at the
december 18 meeting
you know now that you mentioned it
probably both
you know in terms of like i think she
was dead i think she may have been of
the view that she had appointed and was
seeking to
you know
get get that done
and
and and that she should be appointed
as you listen to these clips remember
that ms powell the person who president
trump tried to make special counsel was
ultimately sanctioned by a federal court
and sued by dominion voting systems for
defamation
in her own defense to that lawsuit
sidney powell argued that quote no
reasonable person would conclude
that the statements were truly
statements of fact
not long after sidney powell general
flynn and rudy giuliani giuliani left
the white house in the early hours of
the morning
president trump turned away from both
his outside advisors most outlandish and
unworkable schemes and his white house
counsel's advice to swallow hard and
accept the reality of his loss instead
donald trump issued a tweet that would
galvanize his followers unleash a
political firestorm and change the
course of our history as a country
trump's purpose was to mobilize a crowd
and how do you mobilize a crowd in 2020
with millions of followers on twitter
president trump knew exactly how to do
it at 1 42 a.m on december 19 2020
shortly after the last participants left
the unhinged meeting trump sent out the
tweet
with his explosive invitation
trump repeated his big lie and claimed
it was quote statistically impossible to
have lost the 2020 election
before calling for a big protest in d.c
on january 6th
be there
will be wild
trump supporters responded immediately
women for america first a pro-trump
organizing group had previously applied
for a rally permit for january 22nd and
23rd in washington dc
several days after joe biden was to be
inaugurated
but in the hours after the tweet they
moved their permit to january 6th
two weeks before this rescheduling
created the rally where trump would
eventually speak
the next day
ali alexander
leader of the stop the steel
organization and a key mobilizer of
trump supporters registered
wildprotest.com
named after trump's tweet
wildprotest.com provided comprehensive
information about numerous newly
organized protest events in washington
it included event times
places speakers and details
on transportation in washington d.c
meanwhile other key trump supporters
including far-right media personalities
began promoting
the wild protest on january 6th
it's saturday
december 19th the year is 2020
and one of the most historic events in
american history has just taken place
president trump in the early morning
hours today
tweeted that he wants the american
people to march on washington d.c
on january 6
2021. and now donald trump is calling on
his supporters to descend on washington
d.c
january 6th he is now
calling on we the people to take action
and to show our numbers we're going to
only be saved by millions of americans
moving to washington
occupying the entire
area if if necessary storming right into
the capital
you know there we know the rules of
engagement
if you have enough people you can push
down any kind of offense or a wall this
could be trump's last stand and it's a
time when he has specifically called on
his supporters to arrive in dc
that's something that may actually be
the big push trump supporters need to
say this is it it's now or never you
better understand something son you
better understand something red wave
[ __ ] red white is going to be a red
wedding going down january 6th on that
day trump says
show up for a protest it's gonna be wild
and based on what we've already seen
from the previous events i think trump
is absolutely correct [ __ ] you
better look outside you better look out
for january 6th kick that [ __ ] door
open look down the street you're gonna
be a million of us geeked up armed
americans
the time for games is over the time for
action is now where were you when
history called where were you when you
and your children's destiny and future
was on the line
in that clip you heard one of trump
supporters predict a red wedding which
is a pop culture reference to mass
slaughter but the point is that trump's
call to washington reverberated
powerfully and pervasively online
the committee has interviewed a former
twitter employee
who explained the effect that trump had
on the twitter platform this employee
was on the team responsible for platform
and content moderation policies on
twitter throughout 2020 and 2021 the
employee testified that twitter
considered adopting a stricter content
moderation policy after president trump
told the proud boys to stand back and
stand by from the lectern at the
september 29 presidential debate but
twitter chose not to act here's the
former employee whose voice has been
obscured to protect their identity
discussing trump's stand back and stand
by comment in the effect it had
my concern
was that the former president
for seemingly the first time was
speaking directly to extremist
organizations
and giving them
directives
we had not seen that sort of direct
communication before
um
and
that concerned me
so just to clarify further
um
you were worried others on twitter were
worried that the president might
use
your platform to speak directly to folks
who might be incited to violence
yeah
i believe the twitter relished in the
knowledge that they were also
the
favorite and most used service of
the former president and enjoyed having
that sort of power
within the social media ecosystem if
president trump were anyone else
would it have taken until january 8 2021
for him to be suspended
absolutely not
if donald
former president donald trump or any
other user on twitter he would have been
permanently suspended a very long time
ago
despite these grave concerns trump
remained on the platform completely
unchecked
then came the december 19 tweet and
everything it inspired
indeed
it was it felt as if um
if
a mob was being organized
um and they were
[Music]
gathering together
uh their weaponry and
their
logic
um and their reasoning behind why they
were prepared to fight
um prior to december 19th
um again it was it was vague um it was
it was
non-specific but very clear that
individuals were ready willing and able
to take up arms
after this tweet on december 19th again
it became clear
not only were these individuals ready
and willing
but the leader of
their cause
asking them to join him
in this cause and fighting for this
cause in dc
on january 6 as well
i will also say
what shocked me
was the responses to these tweets right
so these were
a lot of the locked and voted stand back
stand by those tweets were in response
to donald trump saying things like this
right so there would be a response that
said
big protests you see on january 6 be
there be wild and someone bravely
respond and say i'm locked and loaded is
ready for civil war part two right i
very much believe that donald trump
posting this tweet on december 19th was
essentially
staking a flag in
dc on january 6th for his supporters to
come and rally and you were concerned
about the potential for this
gathering becoming violent
absolutely
indeed many of trump's followers took to
social media to declare that they were
ready to answer trump's call
one
user asked
is the sixth d-day is that why trump
wants everyone there
another asserted
trump just told us all to come armed
[ __ ] a this is happening
a third took it even further
it will be wild means we need volunteers
for the firing squad
jim watkins the owner of eight [ __ ] the
fringe online forum that was birthplace
of the
q anon extremist movement confirmed the
importance of trump's tweet
why did you first decide to go to dc for
january 6th when the president of the
united states announced that he was
going to have a rally
then i bought ticket and went
watkins was at the capitol on january
6th
some who have since been indicted for
their
involvement in the attack on the capital
also responded one of them posted on the
19th
quote
calling all patriots be in washington dc
january the 6th
this wasn't organized by any group
djt has invited us and it's going to be
wild
some of the online rhetoric
turned openly homicidal
and white nationalist such as
why don't we just kill them every last
democrat down to the last man woman and
child
and it's time for the day of the rope
white revolution is the only solution
others realize that police would be
standing in the way of their effort to
overturn the election so one wrote
i'm ready to die for my beliefs
are you ready to die police
another wrote on the donald.when
cops don't have standing
if they're laying on the ground in a
pool of their own blood
the donald win was an openly racist and
anti-semitic forum
the select committee deposed that site's
founder jody williams he confirmed how
the president's tweet created a
laser-like focus on the date of january
the sixth
people have been talking about going to
d.c
as soon as the election was over
and do you recall whether or not the
conversation around those dates
centered on the sixth after the
president's tweet
oh sure yeah i mean after it was
announced that you know he was going to
be there on the 6th to talk yes then
then anything else was kind of shut out
and it was just going to be on the 6th
okay and that was
pretty clearly reflected in the the
content on the site
yeah sure
on that site many shared plans and
violent threats
bring handcuffs and wait near the
tunnels wrote one user a commenter
replied suggesting zip ties instead
one post encouraged others to come with
body armor
knuckles shields bats pepper spray
whatever it takes
all of those were used on the sixth the
post concluded
join your local proud boys chapter as
well
the donald dot win featured discussions
of the tunnels beneath the capitol
complex suggestions for targeting
members of congress an encouragement to
attend this once in a lifetime event
while trump's supporters grew more
aggressive online he continued to rile
up his base on twitter
he said there was
overwhelming evidence that the election
was the biggest scam
in our nation's history
as you can see the president continued
to boost the event tweeting about it
more than a dozen times
in the lead up to january the 6th
mr chairman i reserve
the chair requests that those in the
hearing room remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
members from the room
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today the chair declares the
committee in recess for a period of
approximately 10 minutes
so we're going to the break
here on day seven of the january 6 elect
committee hearing
as we watch the
committee leave the room i'm sure when
we come back from the break is when
we'll actually hear from the witnesses
that we expect to hear from today
the former oath keeper and the also the
january 6 rioter
i think we will hear from those
witnesses
when the committee returns
uh gabe what did you think of the some
of the
testimonies so far and some of the
the actual uh
video of some of the testimony
yeah uh i mean sipoloni's saying more
than i thought he would so that's that's
good to see but also i mean just the
mere fact that you know uh
you had sydney powell
you know as she sips on that
that dr pepper
uh you know it's it's funny to see how
all of them kind of reveal like oh well
we all said it was we all said uh we we
should do this thing right and and the
fact that
the fact that they're revealing more
about how
they're saying the opposite of what they
said openly in public
i think is reveal very revealing to what
their intent um
is as each of them you know attempted to
commit sedition and the fact that we had
people like mike lindell and the ceo of
overstock as people that were
influencing the outcome of trying to
overturn this election like what reality
do we live in where some random ceo of a
retail company is the person that's
going to be
the decision maker on how to move
forward
well i mean that that is the you know
the donald trump white house
in a nutshell is just let any rando in
as long as
as long as you'll be
you'll do and say exactly what the
cheeto dust mobster wants right um we
watched as they described
that he didn't care
if if all legal uh uh roads were taken
here
he wanted to overthrow this election he
wanted to remain the president he wanted
to be dictator of the united states of
america and it didn't matter what the
ramifications were right and also the
fact that you had all those people like
tim poole and all the right wing people
who were online ramping up
this
this intensity for january 6th right
talking about this red wedding talking
about how it was going to be intense is
going to be a wild time right i mean
wildprotest.com sounds like something
that is not safe for work you would find
it on some sort of
uh well it just that's i'll just say
it's not safe for work but you look at
these people who were on there fueling
the fire they're literally throwing
kerosene on
getting the trump supporters uh excited
for this right so when you go there it's
hard to try to excuse yourself to say
nobody knew what's gonna happen this got
way out of control it was just a bunch
of people who are trying to express
their patriotism that is complete
[ __ ] when they're doing this they're
stoking the fire and they're getting
these people agitated and they're
getting them riled up for the intent to
get them to cause violence and cause
chaos i i i want to bring in jessica
denson um here
uh to see what she thought of the the
uh testimony that we've seen so far
particularly from um patsy bologna i
mean pat
excuse me um
yes yes yes so what what did you what
did you think of uh the some of the
testimony and some of the deposition
that we heard so far jessica
well i think we've had some very um you
know strategic lawyering from from
individuals like representative raskin
you know circling um cibolone because i
i yes he's making the admissions that we
expected to him to make but i'm also
finding him um to have this air of
disdain for the process this kind of you
know recalcitrance just answering
questions directly but of course um you
know lawyers like raskin are talented
and can get around that and get him to
answer so
he is um you know making all these
obvious concessions that we know you
know trump was told that he lost the
election uh well in advance of january
6th and he was told this repeatedly
we've had haley mcinerney confirm this
we've had um you know ivanka trump again
more testimony from bill barr i mean
just one after another if there was any
doubt
whatsoever that donald trump did not
believe
um that he actually lost the election
that that doubt should be fully
eviscerated at this point
but we're really getting to what i
consider is going to be the real uh the
drama of this hearing today which is the
violence that
donald trump stoked the absolute clear
call to action that the mega extremists
heard when donald trump issued that
tweet and remember this is a tweet that
comes out of this unhinged oval office
meeting where he is frustrated right
because he is not getting the go-ahead
to go forward with his lunatic proposed
plans from individuals like patrick
byrne
ex-ceo of overstock who was um in an
affair with russian operative convicted
russian operative maria boutina so these
are not just randos these are these are
um individuals who do not have
well
you know who who have question very
questionable motivations themselves so
um yeah i'm i'm really interested to see
what comes next and these these two uh
these two witnesses that are coming up
i i agree with you let me bring in texas
paul see what his response was to uh
some of the uh testimony that we we
watched the recorded testimony on texas
paul how are you
yeah he he runs the mic about even
better yeah
yeah uh
game set match i i just
the testimony that you have today is
what they were able to bring to us
now
um
this is game set match when you start
putting these people on the stand
and they're
all of it comes out
this is over
i mean this is over and i'm glad i'm
glad jessica brought up maria boutina
because patrick byrne
had the presidents here the former
presidents here and
a lot of people don't know who he was
and that he was actually the target of a
honeypot maria butini i you know if you
remember when she got home she was
welcomed like a hero they brought her
bouquets of flowers
because she had manipulated these people
she worked inside the nra she worked
inside you know the the inner circle of
the oval office because patrick byrne
could call the president anytime he
wanted
um this this this is just
game set match is all like uh you know
i just kept watching this my jaw kept
dropping because each person that would
testify
just drove another nail in that coffin
that there was no question
that
trump was completely 100 percent briefed
by qualified human beings there's no way
he could have believed any of the
nonsense including the meeting in the
oval office where they're all screaming
at each other and and giuliani the drunk
is calling people you know expletives
and and and
there was no doubt
i mean
simple only just just sat there and
destroyed everything they said and put
them on on on
show me
and another and then
another character was uh hirschmann uh
we know we we've seen him throughout
these hearings with uh him and his
justice bat um but it sounded like
hirschmann and general michael flynn
almost came to blows there
as
hershman just was having none of the
[ __ ] from mike flynn and the
overstock ceo um not even these people
not even knowing who this person was and
i guess that's why i jessica i said
rando is because
the white house counsel the people
around him who are trying to give the
president actual legal advice have no
idea who this person is sitting there
giving the president advice that they
have to work so damn hard to un to
undermine right they have to unravel
this just delusion that the president
wants to believe in that moment because
he wants to be president like have did
you experience this when you were on the
trump team that if there was something
that he really wanted to believe it
doesn't matter how untrue or how
delusional he would go to any means
necessary to get someone he would run
out and get someone standing in front of
a door like hey do you believe me that
way he can believe it himself or
something weird
well what i what i would tell you
definitely resonates with me is that
this unhinged meeting where people are
at each other's necks
is the inevitable outcome of the trump
campaign and trump administration this
was a campaign of mass destruction from
go
i most certainly experienced it this he
fosters an environment where people have
knives out at each other
and he does this to try to pit people
against each other and let let's see who
survives um in this in this last 11th
hour uh effort that he was having in the
oval office obviously he was willing to
throw anything at the wall bring any
kind of rando as you're describing them
into the mix to to achieve his objective
there were no bounds but like i said
this was a campaign of mass destruction
from from the jump and this is we're
seeing the obvious um you know finale in
this hearing today well we watch as the
witnesses have taken their seats here um
for today's um hearing um and we're
waiting on the committee to
return it seems like they're taking a
lot of security measures here gabe yeah
but
what do you expect to hear from these
witnesses i know we've talked to dakota
adams the estranged son of
stuart rhodes the oath keeper's founder
who who uh lived
uh with one of these witnesses or stuart
rhodes lived with him for a while
crashed on the couch yeah yeah as it
were so what do you expect to hear from
some of these as the committee returns
well i'm hoping that this is done out of
a genuine
desire to see justice and not some sort
of attempt to kind of uh throw this
committee under the bus you know so to
speak but um what i'm hoping is to get
an inside look into how
the workings of the of the oath keepers
are right as a spokesman you know he he
knows he knows stuart he knows how they
work he knows exactly what their intent
what their goal is and having some
insight
as a as a direct line in from someone
who was the voice of the oath keepers i
think is going to be paramount to uh
revealing
what the intended goal of using them on
january 6 was
um
you know outside of getting a direct
quote from stuart rhodes or someone but
i think this will be very revealing and
give people a better idea of kind of
what they were planning right and i
think it goes to the
the character witness just not of
stewart rhodes but also all these groups
that we we watched their podcasts their
internet shows uh tim poole um some of
these other personalities that we
watched as that tweet was sent out and
here's the tweet about it will be wild
uh alexander buying the the
wild
pro or protest wild or wild protest.com
um website to try to stoke this violence
and this is in the trump orbit they jump
on these things immediately
and they we've they've done this time
and time and time again with trump um
they continue to do this
as there's something happens they jump
all over it it's kind of like yesterday
hunter biden was trending all day long
because of the hearing today right uh
you know they they continue to do these
things now jessica what do you expect to
hear from these witnesses do you think
we'll we'll get some insight into um
what what the oath keepers were thinking
internally or because it seems like
tettenhoven wasn't involved at that
point but maybe just the mindset
yeah
um yeah ted hogan wasn't van tattenhoven
wasn't involved but he was definitely um
he was a hands-on or not hands-on but
you know first-hand witness to what the
oath keepers were doing and steven ayers
as well these individuals are going to
tell us
very clearly and without a shadow of a
doubt that it was donald trump whose
directive they were following on january
6th it was donald trump their commander
in chief who sent them to the capitol to
overthrow our democracy and to reinstall
him as dictator of course they didn't
think that at the time they were gaslit
believing that his lies were true they
were his useful idiots so you are going
to hear this um as as many january 6th
defendants have raised in their own
defenses in in the cases that the
justice department has brought up until
now we were motivated we were sent we
were following the direction of the
commander-in-chief to be there
uh texas paul and i think he had some
technical difficulties there but we just
we just saw the camera pan over to the
police officers that were defending the
capitol that day and one of these
witnesses was actually a writer who was
possibly fighting with those exact
police officers or their colleagues um
boy you talk about a strong image in a
room of strong images what do you what
do you make of that where the police
officers that were there that day
defending the capitol
are going to sit here and listen to a
january six writer an insurrectionist
testify you know cops
that's what they do man they they they
deal with the scum of the earth and then
they have to sit in a courtroom with
them and watch the same guy that that
was just a total
piece of garbage when he was dealing
with them show up in a suit
nice haircut
you know everything's
it's it's par for the course for them
they i they're it doesn't bother them at
all they've seen it all a hundred times
and anybody that's watched any any kind
of
hearing
knows that's exactly what's going to
happen here today this guy that you're
going to see up there in a suit and tie
when he walks around he's in tactical
gear he's in his camo he's he's you know
this guy right here that you've got
right here this guy
has a fresh haircut fresh suit fresh you
know and he never looks like that
ever he is another one of these
backwoods nuts that i call them
uh you know they're just
these cops have been dealing with this
forever i i you know i i would like to
add in
in watching this i each of these
hearings it was really watching this
hearing that really kind of struck me
each one you know we've always had
something huge happen
and we're like wow wow wow but this one
it seems like it feels like this would
turn into a corner
you know this is really
donald trump has decided
okay we couldn't do it with the courts
we couldn't do it by this means we
couldn't do it by that means
this hearing is really the
screw it we're going for broke and we're
going to have us a revolution
well i i think that also feeling through
it yeah i think that speaks to kind of
what options were left which were none
right they explored legal options they
got shut down and the only way for him
to take over was to physically take it
and that is going to be revealed which
would be the oath keepers the proud boys
the you know the militiamen that are
going to be the ones will he be his you
know his strong hand
to uh to to take what he wants what he
believes is his
um and i think that's that's you know
whether things kind of lined up that way
or that was always the goal in terms of
saying uh we've shown you how he's
attempted all these places and everyone
has said along the way it was not gonna
happen it was not fraud
uh all of these cabinet members and now
he's like screw it i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna take how i want it
and i'm going to use the force of these
people to do it so
you know i think that's that that could
be one of the strategies i mean the
other thing too i think with the capitol
police here is
the i think the big difference between
cops you know having to be in a
courtroom is you have
a party that gaslit these gentlemen
these and women uh that are the capitol
police and saying oh it was just a
tourist visit you know you're
overreacting these aren't you know these
weren't uh uh traumatic events that you
experienced and so i think it does maybe
sitting a little different to actually
be in the room with them right now and
looking over
at someone who is directly at the
capitol and involved with the violence
against them i think it definitely
kind of hits a different uh different
tone for them but that's just you know
kind of my assumption seems like we're
waiting on the committee to
enter
um
i don't know we have we haven't waited
this long makes you makes you wonder uh
yeah i don't know you know gabe
hit a really good point there is how
badly these people have been gaslit i
just did a video that's going to come
probably come out today or in the
morning
uh about the last trump rally up in
alaska uh he is still gaslighting to
this day he brought he brought out you
know russia's down to the old war relics
when they're fighting in ukraine because
all their good stuff's gone gop is in
the same position they dug up sarah
palin they're down to the old old war
relics that they're digging out but uh
she was
giving this same
exact
message in her speech that she gave at
that trump rally pure gaslighting it's
good versus evil
in their minds they because that's what
they keep getting told
over and over and over again and there
and and you know i've done several
videos about how they're trying to morph
into the party of of of god
it's a christian fascist movement now
and they really believe
because of all of this gaslighting they
have hurt so many people financially
they've hurt so many people's
relationships with their families
they've hurt so many people in so many
ways that absolutely believe
what gabe was talking about that that
gaslighting that never
ever stops and jess couldn't tell you
about it she's she's she's seen it
happen
you know from both ends you know i mean
it's just a never stop
message that never
never alters never veers never anything
drive driven into their heads well
jessica tell us about the um what you
see with this krishna christian
nationalism because i know you have some
opinions about it um especially being
inside the trump camp at some at one
point um and
the blasphemous nationalism yes the
non-christian
anti-christian so-called christianity
fashion i knew i could rely on you
giving your opinion
the ones these are the people who would
um be casting stones at jesus christ if
he were hanging on a cross today let's
just be clear about this
um
but yeah it is this is exactly what paul
was saying these people cloak themselves
in moral authority they cloak themselves
in the bible and the american flag their
followers so tragically because they are
in this vortex of misinformation where
they tell you you can't even listen to
the other side don't even bother
hearing what they have to say because
they've completely just delegitimized
other voices and they have created idols
of themselves at fox news idols of you
know donald trump is their ultimate idol
their god
and they they worship at his altar um
tragically
tragically believing that he is um you
know a patriot an american uh somebody
who cares about this country and for
god's sake freedom which is the most
dangerous lie that they believe that
donald trump is a champion of freedom
when he is really
you know hitler 2.0 putin 2.0 um the
dictator that wants to destroy
everything that america stands for
i i knew i could count on you giving
your your opinion there jessica everyone
uh go if you're not already subscribe to
the mindsets network here on youtube we
will continue these hearings we've we
heard eliza chaney really teasing uh the
next earring it seems like it's going to
be a prime time hearing so again
subscribe to the minus touch network
here on youtube you don't want to miss a
single one of these hearings and you
don't want to miss a single one of the
great videos like texas paul was talking
about earlier where we bring you
breaking news from the midas touch
network and the minded touch
personalities right on the youtube
channel so do that also i i would be
derelict in my duty if i didn't mention
the
the uh
the promo code for the
store.minustouch.com
get 10 off the pro democracy enamel
print the unapologetically pro-democracy
union made
in the usa enamel pen so there you go
jordy i know he's probably listening out
there ten percent off just use the promo
code justice go to store.midastouch.com
one thing i want to add to what jessica
uh just said is you know revealing
obviously we all know right the gop is
is full of hypocrisy projection um you
know they contradict themselves within
the same state statement
um
but we especially saw that in the uh
in the hearing with
uh rusty bowers and brad rappenberger
right like you hear the story of
rusty bowers saying my wife was directly
impacted by the horrific uh you know
protesting if you want to call it that
outside their homes as well as their
daughter who was gravely ill at the time
then you got brad raffensberger who sons
widow
her home was broken into like this is
magga this is trump's republican party
that is what it is right now they will
attack their own
if trump says to right if you go against
what his story is what his narrative uh
what his
um
you know direction is then you will be
on the opposite side of the fence for
them right you you will be the target in
which they want to attack and it is
crazy because if they really were
christians if they really were people
who were you know followers of christ
then they would want to love one another
right they wouldn't want to disrespect
they wouldn't want to do illegal things
they wouldn't want to attack someone
uh but unfortunately like it is just a
facade it's just a label that they can
hide behind to
uh act moral and act on a high ground
but really
dig in and be
morally corrupt
because because ron reagan and them had
a great point about that
hanging there hanging their texas ball
we're going to have the committee come
back thank you panel for joining us in
the break we're going to go to the uh
the panel here or the hearing here
back to the coverage they were having a
bit of technical difficulty here but i
think they've cleared it up so back to
the hearing as we go
we'll watch as benny thompson gavels in
to hear from the witness and get the
testimony of the former oath keeper and
the january 6th writer who has pled
guilty
let's go to the hearing
committee will be in order
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
maryland mr raskin
mr chairman president trump's tweet
drew tens of thousands of americans to
washington to form the angry crowd that
would be transformed on january the
sixth into a violent mob
dr dannell harvin who was the chief of
homeland security and intelligence for
dc
told the committee how his team
saw trump's december 19th tweet unite
violent groups
across the spectrum on the far right
we we got derogatory information from
ocean suggesting that uh some very very
violent individuals uh were organizing
uh to come to dc and not only were they
um organizing from the d.c but they were
these groups uh these non-aligned uh
groups were aligning um and so the the
red all the red flags went up at that
point
you know when you have our militia um uh
you know collaborating with white
supremacy groups
collaborating with um
uh conspiracy theory groups online all
for the common goal
you start seeing uh what we call in in
you know terrorism of blended ideology
and that's a very very bad sign then
when they were clearly across
not just across one platform but across
multiple platforms with these groups
coordinating not just like chatting hey
how's it going you know
what's the weather like where you're at
but like what are you bringing what are
you wearing oh you know
where where do we meet up uh do you have
plans for the capital that's operational
that's like pre-operational intelligence
right um and that that is something
that's clearly alarming
the proud boys and the oath keepers are
two key groups
that responded immediately to president
trump's call the proud boys are a
far-right street fighting group that
glorifies violence and white supremacy
the oath keepers are extremists who
promote a wide range of conspiracy
theories and sought to act as a private
paramilitary force for donald trump
the department of justice has charged
leaders of both groups with seditious
conspiracy to overthrow the government
of the united states on january the 6th
trump's december 19th tweet motivated
these two extremist groups which have
historically not worked together to
coordinate their activities
december 19th at 10 22 a.m just hours
after president trump's tweet kelly
meigs the head of the florida oath
keepers declared an alliance among the
oath keepers the proud boys in the
florida three percenters another militia
group he wrote we have decided to work
together and shut this [ __ ] down
phone records obtained by the select
committee show that later that afternoon
mr meigs called proud boys leader
enrique tario and they spoke for several
minutes the very next day the proud boys
got to work
the proud boys launched an encrypted
chat called the ministry of self-defense
the committee obtained hundreds of these
messages which show strategic and
tactical planning about january the 6th
including
maps of washington dc that pinpoint the
location of police in the weeks leading
up to the attack leaders in both the
proud boys and the oath keepers worked
with trump allies one such ally was
lieutenant general michael flynn trump's
former national security adviser and one
of the participants in the unhinged
meeting at the white house on december
18th
he also had connections to the oath
keepers
this photo from december 12th
shows flynn and patrick byrne another
trump ally who was present at that
december 18th meeting
guarded by indicted oath keeper roberto
minuta
another view of the scene shows
oathkeeper's leader stuart rhodes
in the picture as well
another central figure with ties to this
network of extremist groups was roger
stone a political consultant and long
time confidant of president trump
he pardoned both flynn and stone in the
weeks between the election on november
3rd and january 6th
in the same time frame stone
communicated with both the proud boys
and the oath keepers regularly the
committee obtained encrypted content
from a group
from a group chat called friends of
stone fos which included stone rhodes
tario and ali alexander the chat focused
on various pro-trump events in november
and december of 2020 as well as january
6th
as you can see here stewart rhodes
himself urged the friends of stone to
have people go to their state capitals
if they could not make it to washington
for the first million meg of march on
november 14th these friends of roger
stone had a significant presence at
multiple pro-trump events after the
election including in washington on
december the 12th on that day stuart
rhodes called for donald trump to invoke
martial law promising bloodshed if he
did not
he needs to know from you that you are
with him that he does not do it now
while he is commander in chief we're
going to have to do it ourselves later
in a much more desperate much more
bloody war let's get it on now while he
is still the commander-in-chief
that night the proud boys engaged in
violence on the streets of washington
and hurled aggressive insults at the
police
breakers
do your [ __ ] job
give us one hour
one hour
just the previous night the co-host of
infowars issued an ominous warning at a
rally alongside roger stone and proud
boys leader enrique tario
[Applause]
we will be back
[Music]
[Applause]
encrypted chats obtained by the select
committee showed that kelly meigs the
indicted leader of the florida
oathkeeper spoke directly with roger
stone about security on january 5th and
6th
in fact
on january 6 stone was guarded by two
oath keepers who have since been
criminally indicted for seditious
conspiracy one of them later pleaded
guilty and according to the department
of justice admitted that the oath
keepers were ready to use quote lethal
force if necessary against anyone who
tried to remove president trump from the
white house including the national guard
as we've seen the proud boys were also
part of the friends of stone network
stone's ties to the proud boys go back
many years he's even taken their
so-called fraternity creed required for
the first level of initiation to the
group
hi i'm roger stone i'm a western
children's and i refuse to apologize
[Music]
kelly sorell a lawyer who assists the
oath keepers and a volunteer lawyer for
the trump campaign explained to the
committee how roger stone and other
figures brought extremists of different
stripes and views together
you mentioned that mr stone wanted to
start the stop the steel series of
rallies
who did you consider the leader of these
rallies it sounds like from what you
just said it was
mr stone mr jones and mr ally alexander
is that correct
those are the ones that became like the
the center point for everything
we'll learn more from ms murphy about
these individuals and their involvement
in the days leading up to the violent
attack on january 6th we'll also hear
how they were allowed to speak at a
rally for president trump the night
before january 6 even though organizers
had expressed serious concerns about
their violent and extremist rhetoric
directly to mark meadows and you'll hear
testimony from white house aides who
were with the president as he watched
the crowd from the oval office and will
testify about how excited he was for the
following day
let me note now that our investigation
continues on these critical issues we
have only shown
a small fraction of what we have found i
look forward to the public release of
more of our findings later mr chairman
and i now yield back
gentlemen years back chair recognizes
this gentlewoman from florida miss
murphy
during our most recent hearing the
committee showed some evidence of what
president trump chief of staff mark
meadows and other white house officials
knew about the potential for violence on
january 6.
and despite this information they made
no effort to cancel the rally halt the
march to the capitol or even to lower
the temperature among president trump's
supporters
katrina pearson one of the organizers of
january 6 rally and a former campaign
spokeswoman for president trump grew
increasingly apprehensive after learning
that multiple activists had been
proposed as speakers for the january 6
rally
these included some of the people we
discussed earlier in this hearing
roger stone a long long-time outside
advisor to president trump
alex jones the founder of the conspiracy
theory website infowars
and ali alexander an activist known for
his violent political rhetoric
on december 30th ms pearson exchanged
text messages with another key rally
organizer about why people like mr
alexander and mr jones were being
suggested as speakers at the president's
rally on january 6. ms pearson's
explanation was
potus and she remarked that the
president likes the crazies
the committee asked ms pearson about
these messages and this is what she said
so when you said that he likes the
crazies were you talking about president
trump
yes i was talking about president trump
he loved people who viciously defended
him in public but consistent in terms of
the support for these people at least
with what the president likes from what
you could tell
yes the the people that would
be very very vicious in publicly
defending him
on january 2nd ms pearson's concerns
about the potential rally speakers had
grown serious enough that she reached
out to mr meadows directly
she wrote
good afternoon would you mind giving me
a call regarding this january 6 event
things have gotten crazy and i
desperately need some direction please
according to phone records obtained by
the committee ms pearson received a
phone call from mr meadows eight minutes
later
here's what ms pearson said about that
conversation
so what specifically did you tell him
though about other
other events just that there were a
bunch of entities coming in
some were very suspect but they're going
to be on other on other stages some on
other days a very very brief overview
of what was actually happening um and
why i raised the red flags
and when you told him that people were
very suspect what what did did you tell
him what you meant by that or what did
you convey to him about what your
the problems with these
folks i think i even texted him some of
my concerns um but i did briefly go over
some of the concerns that i had raised
to everybody with alex jones or ali
alexander and some of the rhetoric that
they were doing
i probably mentioned to him
that they had already caused trouble at
other capitals are at the previous event
the previous march that they did for
protesting
and i just had a concern about it
miss pearson was especially concerned
about ali alexander and alex jones
because in november 2020 both men and
some of their supporters had entered the
georgia state capitol to protest the
results of the 2020 election ms pearson
believed that she mentioned this to mark
meadows on this january 2nd call
notably january 2nd is the same day on
which according to cassidy hutchinson
miss meadows mr meadows warned her of
things
that things might get real real bad on
january 6.
after her january second call with mr
meadows katrina pearson sent an email to
fellow rally organizers she wrote potus
expectations are to have something
intimate at the ellipse and call on
everyone to march to the capitol
president's own documents suggest that
the president
had decided to call on his supporters to
go to the capitol on january 6 but that
he chose not to widely announce it until
his speech on the ellipse that morning
the committee has obtained this draft
updated
undated tweet from the national archives
it includes a stamp stating president
has seen
the draft tweet reads i will be making a
big speech at 10 a.m on january 6 at the
ellipse south of the white house please
arrive early massive crowds expected
march to the capitol after stop this
deal
although this tweet was never sent rally
organizers were discussing and preparing
for the march to the capitol in the days
leading up to january 6.
this is a january 4th text message from
a rally organizer to mike lindell the my
pillow ceo the organizer says
you know this stays between us we're
having a second stage at the supreme
court again after the ellipse
potus is going to have us march there
slash the capital it cannot get out
about the second stage because people
will try and set up another and sabotage
it it can also not get out about the
march because i will be in trouble with
the national park service and all the
agencies but potus is going to just call
for it quote unexpectedly
the end of the message indicates that
the president's plan to have his
followers march to the capitol was not
being broadly discussed
and then on the morning of january 5th
ali alexander whose firebrand style
concerned katrina pearson sent a similar
text to a conservative journalist
mr alexander said tomorrow ellipse then
u.s capitol trump is supposed to order
us to the capitol at the end of his
speech but we will see
president trump did follow through on
his plan using his january 6 speech to
tell his supporters to march to the
capitol on january 6.
the evidence confirms that this was not
a spontaneous call to action but rather
was a deliberate strategy decided upon
in advance by the president
another part of the president's strategy
involved certain members of congress who
amplified his unsupported assertions
that the election had been stolen
in the weeks after the election the
white house coordinated closely with
president trump's allies in congress to
disseminate his false claims and to
encourage members of the public to fight
the outcome on january six
we know that the president met with
various members to discuss january 6
well before the joint session
the president's private schedule for
december 21 2020 shows a private meeting
with republican members of congress
we know that vice president pence chief
of staff mark meadows and rudy giuliani
also attended that meeting
we obtained an email that was sent from
congressman mo brooks of alabama to mark
meadows setting up that meeting
the subject line is white house meeting
december 21st regarding january 6.
in his email congressman brooks
explained that he had not asked anyone
to join him in the quote january 6
effort
because in his view quote only citizens
can exert the necessary influence on
senators and congressmen to join this
fight against massive voter fraud and
election theft
at this point you may also recall
testimony given in our earlier hearing
by acting attorney general richard
donahue who said that the president
asked the department of justice to quote
just say that the election was corrupt
and leave the rest to me and the
republican congressmen
according to white house visitor logs
obtained by the committee members of
congress present at the white house on
december 21st included congressman brian
babin
andy biggs
matt gates
louis gomart
paul gosar
andy harris
jody heiss
jim jordan and scott perry
then congresswoman-elect marjorie
taylor-green was also there
we heard testimony in an early hearing
that a pardon was ultimately requested
by congressman mo brooks and other
members of congress who attended this
meeting
we've asked witnesses what happened
during the december 21st meeting and
we've learned that part of the
discussion centered on the role of the
vice president during the counting of
the electoral votes
these members of congress were
discussing what would later be known as
the eastman theory which was being
pushed by attorney john eastman
in one of our earlier hearings you heard
in great detail that president trump was
trying to convince vice president pence
to do something illegal
his white house counsel confirmed all of
that in testimony last week
your view mr siblone upon that those
discussions with mr filled in with greg
jacob what was your assessment as to
what the vice president could or could
not do at the
what was my assessment about what your
coder couldn't do yes your view of the
issue my view was that the vice
president
had didn't have a legal authority to do
anything except what he did they both
told us mr philbin and mr jacob that
they looked very closely at the eastman
memos the eastern theory and thought
that it had no basis that it was not a
strategy that the
president should pursue sounds like
that's consistent with your question as
well
my impression would have been informed
certainly by them
campaign senior advisor jason miller
told us that mr cipollini thought john
eastman's theories were nutty something
mr sipoloni wouldn't refute
we've received testimony from various
people about this uh one was jason
miller who was a campaign
said that that waves communicated to me
was that pats of colombia thought the
idea was nutty and at one point
confronted eastman basically with the
same sentiment
i don't have any reason to contradict
what he said
on january 4th john eastman went to the
white house to meet with the president
and vice president mr sipolini tried to
participate in this meeting but he was
apparently turned away
you didn't go to the meeting in the oval
office where easton met with the
president
do you know
do you remember why you didn't
personally attend
i did walk to that meeting and i did go
into the oval office with the idea of
attending that meeting and then i
ultimately did not attend that meeting
why not
the reasons for that are privileged
okay were you asked to not attend the
meeting or did you make
recall that greg jacob the vice
president's council stated that mr
eastman acknowledged he would lose 9-0
if his legal theory were challenged in
the supreme court
mr sipolini had reviewed mr eastman's
legal theory and expressed his view
repeatedly that the vice president was
right he even offered to take the blame
for the vice president's position
i thought that the vice president
did not have the authority
to do what was being suggested
under a proper reading of the law i
conveyed that okay i think i actually
thought somebody you know in the vice
president's just blame me this you know
this is i'm not a politician
you know i don't
and but you know i just said i'm a
lawyer this is my legal opinion
i
but let me tell you this can i say a
word about the vice president please i
think the vice president did the right
thing
i think he did the courageous thing
i have a great deal of respect for vice
president pence
i worked with him very closely
i think he understood my opinion i think
he understood my opinion afterwards as
well
i think he did a great service for this
country
and
i think i i suggested to somebody that
he should be getting in the presidential
battle for his actions
earlier this year a federal district
district court judge concluded that
president trump and mr eastman relying
on mr eastman's theory more likely than
not violated multiple federal criminal
laws in their pressure campaign against
the vice president
also recall earlier in this hearing we
saw that rudy giuliani's team did not
have actual evidence of fraud sufficient
to change the result of the election
that's important because as january 6
approached the republican members of the
house and senate were looking for
reason to object to the electors
and no real evidence was ever given to
them and we know that republican members
of the house received a memorandum from
the chairwoman of the house republican
caucus in the days before january 6
explaining in detail the many
constitutional and legal problems with
objections and describing the principal
judicial rulings dismissing the claims
of widespread fraud
but their plan to object to the
certification of the election on january
6 went forward anyway
the next day on january 5th the day
before the attack on the capital tens of
thousands of people converged on
washington
while certain close associates of
president trump privately expressed
concerns about what would occur on
january 6.
other members of the president's inner
circle spoke with great anticipation
about the events to come
the committee has learned from the white
house phone logs that the president
spoke to steve bannon his close advisor
at least twice on january 5th
the first conversation they had lasted
for 11 minutes listen to what mr bannon
said that day after the first call he
had with the president
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow it's all converging and now
we're on as they say the point of attack
right the point of attack tomorrow i'll
tell you this
it's not going to happen like you think
it's gonna happen okay it's gonna be
quite extraordinarily different and all
i can say is strap in
from those same phone logs we know that
the president and mr bannon spoke again
on the phone that evening this time for
six minutes
that same day on the eve of january 6
supporters of president trump gathered
in washington d.c at another rally this
rally was held at freedom plaza which is
located near the white house and
featured some of the speakers who
katrina pearson and others deemed too
extreme to share the stage with the
president the next morning
and as this rally was underway
the president asked members of his staff
to come to the oval office
let's hear from the white house aides
who were in the oval office that night
i was in the office in the oval office
and he had asked me to
open the door
so that he could hear
i guess there was a concert or a wrap of
something going on
did he say anything other than just open
the door
he he made a comment i don't remember
specifically what he said but there's a
lot of energy when we walked in
the staff was um
kind of standing up and assembled along
the wall and the president was at the
desk uh and
dance gavino was on the couch
and the president was
dictating a tweet that he wanted um
scouting out to send out then
the president started talking about the
rally the next day um
he had the door of um the oval open to
the rose garden because you could hear
the crowd already assembled outside on
the ellipse and they were
playing music
and
it was so loud that you could feel it
shaking in the oval he was in a very
good mood and i say that because
he had not been in a good mood for weeks
leading up to that and then it seemed
like he was in a fantastic mood
that evening he asked
if
if members of congress would be with him
tomorrow
and what do you understand by me voting
in his favor as opposed to physically
with him or anything like that
yeah and i took that to mean
not voting to certify the election then
he did
look to the staff and ask for
um ideas of how
if i recall that we could make the
rhinos do the right thing
is the way he phrased it and um
no one spoke up initially because i
think everyone was trying to process
what that he meant by that the
president was making notes then talking
then
about we should go up to the capitol
what's the best route to go to the
capitol
i said
you should focus on policy
accomplishments i didn't mention
what was his response
he acknowledged that and
said we've had a lot
something along those lines and
but then he
fairly quickly moved to
how fired up the crowd
is
was going to be
what did he say about it
um
just that they were they were fired up
they were angry they feel like
the election has been celebrated the
election was rigged
did he get any indication of how he knew
that the crowd was fired up or angry he
continued to reference being able to
hear them outside
through the open door of the oval office
the president could hear the sound of
the crowd and the music at the rally at
the freedom
plaza and these are some of the things
that they were saying there at the plaza
just blocks from where the president sat
that evening excited for the next day
this is nothing less than an epic
struggle for the future of this country
between dark and light
between the godly and the godless
between good and evil
and we will win this fight or america
would step off into a thousand years of
darkness
tomorrow
tomorrow trust me
the american people that are standing on
the soil that we are standing on tonight
and they're going to be standing on this
soil tomorrow this is soil that we have
fought over fought for and we will fight
for in the future
the members
the members of congress the members of
the house of representatives the members
of the of the united states senate those
of the those of you who are feeling weak
tonight those of you that don't have the
moral fiber in your body get some
tonight because tomorrow we the people
going to be here and we want you to know
that we will not stand for a lie
we will not stand for a lie
i want them to know
that
1776 is always an option
these degenerates and the teeth say are
going to give us what we want or we are
going to shut this country down
it's 17 76
17 76
17 76
17 76.
at 505 pm as the freedom plaza rally was
underway just blocks away president
trump tweeted
washington is being inundated with
people who don't want to see an election
victory stolen by emboldened radical
left democrats
our country has had enough they won't
take it anymore to the crowds gathering
in d.c he added we hear you and love you
from the oval office
the committee has learned that on
january 5th there were serious concerns
at twitter about the anticipated
violence the next day
listen to what the twitter witness told
us about their desperate efforts to get
twitter to do something
what was your your gut feeling on the
night of january 5th i believe i sent
a slack message to someone that said
something along the lines of
when people are shooting each other
tomorrow i will try and rest
in the knowledge that we tried
um and so i went to i don't know that i
slept that night to be honest with you
um i
i was on pins and needles um
because again for
for months i had been
begging and
anticipating and attempting to
[Music]
raise the reality that if nothing if we
made no intervention into what i saw the
korean people were going to die
um
and
on january 5th i realized
no intervention was coming uh and no
there and even as as hard as i had tried
to
create one uh or implement one
there was nothing and we were
we were at the limbs um in the mercy of
a violent crowd
that was locked and loaded
and just for the record this was content
that was echoing
statements by the former president but
also
proud boys
and other
known violent extremist groups
yeah
there were also concerns
among members of congress we have a
recently released recording of a
conversation that took place among
republican members in the u.s capitol on
the eve of january 6. this is republican
congresswoman debbie lesko from arizona
who led some of the unfounded objections
to the election results
i also asked leadership to come up with
a safety plan for members
i'm actually very concerned about this
because we have
who knows how many hundreds of thousands
of people coming here we have antifa
uh we also have quite honestly trump
supporters who actually believe
that we are going to overturn the
election and when that doesn't happen
most likely will not happen
they are going to go nuts
that same evening as president trump
listened to the rally from the oval
office he was also working on his speech
to be delivered the next day
and based on documents we've received
from the national archives including
multiple drafts of the president's
speech as well as from witness testimony
we understand how that speech devolved
into a call to action and a call to
fight
one of the first edits president trump
made to his speech was to incorporate
his 505 pm tweet revising his speech to
say
all of us are here today
do not want to see our election victory
stolen by emboldened radical left
democrats our country has had enough we
will not take it anymore he also added
together we will stop the steel
president trump's edits continued into
the morning of january 6.
and as you can see from the president's
daily diary here
the president spoke to his chief
speechwriter stephen miller for over 25
minutes that morning
following his call with mr miller
president trump inserted for the first
time a line in his speech that said
quote
and we will see whether mike pence
enters history as a truly great and
courageous leader all he has to do is
refer the illegally submitted electoral
votes back to the states that were given
false and fraudulent information where
they want to re-certify
no prior version of this speech had
referenced vice president pence or his
role during the joint session on january
6.
these last-minute edits by president
trump to his speech were part of the
president's pressure campaign against
his own vice president
but not everyone wanted these lines
regarding the vice president included in
the president's speech including white
house lawyer eric hirschman
did you ever speak to anybody in the
white house at the time about this
disagreement between the president and
vice president other than the president
based on the objection from your counsel
um
maybe had a brief conversation about it
with uh eric hershman
tell me about that what do you remember
him saying to you about this
disagreement
i just remember him um
saying that um
get this wrong i was sort of similar to
the effect of um
thinking that it would be
counterproductive i think he thought to
um
uh to discuss the matter publicly
so it came up in the context of editing
the president's speech on january the
6th
i just came to the conversation where
eric knew it was in the speech and so he
had a
sidebar with me about it
and so the speechwriters took that
advice and removed the lines about vice
president pence
later that morning at 11 20 a.m
president trump had a phone call with
the vice president
and as the committee detailed in an
earlier hearing that phone call was by
all accounts tense and heated
during this call the vice president told
pr the president that he would not
attempt to change the outcome of the
election
in response the president called the
vice president of the united states a
wimp and other derogatory words
as you can see in this email after vice
president pence told president trump
that he would not unilaterally deliver
him a second term in office
the speechwriters were directed to
reinsert the mike pence lines
here's how one of the speechwriters
described president trump's last minute
change to the speech
and
as i recall there was a very tough
a tough sentence
about the vice president
that was that was was added
president trump wanted to use his speech
to attack vice president pence in front
of a crowd of thousands of angry
supporters who had been led to believe
the election was stolen
when president trump arrived at the
ellipse to deliver his speech he was
still worked up from his call with vice
president pence and although ivanka
trump would not say so her chief of
staff gave the committee some insight
into the president's frustration
it's been reported that you ultimately
decided to attend the rally because you
hoped that you would calm the president
and keep the event on an even keel
is that accurate
no i i don't know who said that or where
that came from
what did she share with you about why it
was concerning that her father was
upset or agitated after that call with
vice president pence in relation to the
ellipse rally why did that matter
why did he have to be calmed down i
should say
well she shared that he had called the
vice president and not
an expletive word
i think that bothered her and i think
she could tell based on the
conversations and what was going on in
the office
that
he was
angry and upset and people were
providing this information
and she felt like
she might be able to help calm this
situation down
um
at least before he went on to stage
the president did go on stage and then
he gave the speech that he wanted to
give it included the formal changes he
had requested the night before
and in that morning but also many
important last-minute ad-lib changes
a single scripted reference in the
speech to mike pence became eight
a single scripted reference to
rally-goers marching to the capital
became four with president trump
ad-libbing that he would be joining the
protesters at the capitol
added throughout his speech were
references to fighting and the need for
people to have courage and to be strong
the word peacefully was in the staff
written script and used only once
here are some of these ad-lib changes
that the president made to his speech
because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
so i hope mike has the courage to do
what he has to do
and i hope he doesn't listen to the
rhinos and the stupid people that he's
listening to
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
but we're going to try and give our
republicans
the weak ones because the strong ones
don't need any of our help
we're going to try and give them
the kind of pride
and boldness that they need to take back
our country
so let's walk down pennsylvania avenue
white house counsel pat sipoloni and his
deputy did not attend the speech and
they were concerned that the statements
in the speech about the election were
false
in fact the message that president trump
delivered that day was built on a
foundation of lies
he lied to his supporters that the
election was stolen he stoked their
anger
he called for them to fight for him he
directed them to the u.s capitol he told
them he would join them and his
supporters believed him and many headed
towards the capitol
as a result people died people were
injured
many of his supporters lives will never
be the same
president trump's former campaign
manager brad parskal recognized the
impact of the speech immediately and
this is what he said on january 6 in
excerpts from text messages to katrina
pearson
mr parskal said quote
this is about trump pushing for
uncertainty in our country a sitting
president asking for civil war
and then when he said this week i feel
guilty for helping him win
katrina pearson responded
you did what you felt right at the time
and therefore it was right
mr parskal added yeah but a woman is
dead
and yeah if i was trump and i knew my
rhetoric killed someone
when miss pearson replied it wasn't the
rhetoric mr pascal said katrina yes it
was
thank you mr chairman i yield back
generator yields back
we're joined today
by mr jason van tavenholt
and mr steven ayers
mr
tayton hold is an artist and journal
journalist he's a former spokesman
of the oath keepers and a former close
associate of elma stewart rhodes the
founder and president of those keepers
who has been charged with seditious
conspiracy in relation to the capital
attack
mr van taten hove broke with the oath
keepers and has since spoken out
forcefully against the violent group
mr az is a former supporter of president
trump he answered the president's call
to come to washington d.c on january 6.
he marched to the capitol on the
president's orders he pleaded guilty
last month to disorderly and disruptive
conduct at the capitol
mr az who no longer supports president
trump came forward voluntarily
to share his story as a warning
i will now swear in our witnesses the
witnesses will please stand and raise
their right name
do you swear our firm on the penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you you may be seated
let the record reflect that the
witnesses answered
in the affirmative
i recognize myself for questions
today we've discussed how president
trump summoned an angry mob of
supporters to washington d.c
many of whom came prepared to do battle
against police and politicians alike
we're fortunate enough to be joined by
two witnesses who can help us understand
who was in the mob that day
both hardcore violent extremists like
the oath keepers and proud boys and
average trump supporters swept up in the
favor of the day
mr van taten hold can you help us
understand
who the oath keepers are
i can thank you
my time with the oath keepers began back
at bundy ranch with that first standoff
when i went to cover them as an
independent journalist
i then subsequently
covered
two more standoffs the sugar pine mine
standoff and the white hope mine
standoff it was at that time that i was
offered a job
as national media director and an
associate editor for the web page
so i spent a few years with the oath
keepers and
i can tell you that
they may not like to call themselves a
militia but they are
they're a violent militia
and
they are largely stewart rhodes
um
they um and i i think
rather than try to use words i think the
the best illustration for what the oath
keepers are
happened january 6th when we saw that
stacked military formation
going up the stairs of our capital
i saw radicalization that
started with my beginning of my time
with them
and continued
over a period of time as
the member base and and who it was that
uh stuart rhodes was courting
um
drifted further and further right into
the alt-right world
into white nationalists and even
straight up racists
and um
it came to a point where i could no
longer
continue to to
work for them
but the oath keepers are
are a dangerous militia that that is in
large part fed by
the ego and and drive of stuart rhodes
who at times seem to see himself as
this
paramilitary leader
um i think that drove a lot of it
so
in in my opinion the oath keepers are a
very dangerous organization
well thank you very much you've talked a
little bit about that danger so
what is the oath keepers vision for
america
and why should americans be concerned
about it
i think we saw a glimpse of
what the vision of the oath keepers is
on january 6th
it doesn't necessarily include the rule
of law
it doesn't necessarily include
it includes violence it includes
trying to to get their way through lies
through deceit
through intimidation and through the the
perpetration of violence
the swaying of of people who may not
know better through lies and rhetoric
and propaganda
that can get swept up in these movement
moments
and i'll admit i was swept up at one
point as well too
um
but
i i don't know if that answers the
question well it does and uh you talk
about being swept up
so at what point did you break with the
old keepers
there came a point
there were many red flags and i probably
should have broke with them much earlier
than i did
um but the the straw that broke the
camel's back really came when i walked
into
um a grocery store we were living up in
the uh very remote town of eureka
montana and
um there was a group of
core members of the group of the oath
keepers and some associates and they
were having a conversation
at that
public area where they were talking
about how the holocaust was not real
and that was for me something i just
could not abide
and you know we were not
we were not
wealthy people at all we were barely
surviving and it didn't matter um i went
home to my wife and my kids and i told
them that
i've got to walk away at this point
i don't know how we're going to survive
or where we're going to go what we're
going to do
but i just can no longer continue and
put in my resignation
thank you very much
mr ayers
there were many people in the crowd that
day january 6 including you
who are not part of an extremist group
i'd like to start by having you tell the
american people
a little bit about yourself
can you tell us about your life before
january 6th
yeah um
basically nothing but a family man and a
working man
worked at the company
a cabinet company up in northeast ohio
for
going on 20 years um
you know family's my life
my you know i was a supervisor there so
that that took up a lot of my other
you know a lot of my free time
i'm other than that
with my family camping playing
basketball playing games with my son
just what any ordinary american citizen
family man would do yep exactly
so the this committee has reviewed
thousands of hours of surveillance
footage from january 6.
during this review we identified you
entering the capitol
as we see in this video
mrs why did you decide to come
to washington on january 6th
for me for me personally
you know uh
i was
you know
pretty hardcore
into the social media facebook
twitter instagram i followed you know
president trump
you know on all the websites you know
um
you basically put out you know
come to stop the steel rally you know i
felt like i needed to be down here
so so you basically learned about the
rally on social media and
at some point made a decision to come to
washington yeah yeah
um i had some friends i found out were
coming down i just hopped you know
hopped on with them right at the tail
end when i found out and
came down here with them
thank you very much the chair recognizes
the vice chair miss cheney of wyoming
for any questions she may have
thank you very much mr chairman
mr ayers when you entered the capitol
last year did you believe that the
election had been stolen
at that time yeah you know everything
that i was i was seeing online
um
i definitely
believe that that's exactly what that
was the case
and when uh
you heard from president trump that the
election was stolen how did that make
you feel
oh i was you know i was very upset
um as were most of his supporters um
you know that's basically what got me to
come down here
and do you still believe the election
was stolen
not so much now um i got away from all
the social media
when january 6 happened
basically deleted it all
you know i started doing my own research
and everything and
for me for me
for something like that to be that
actually for that to actually take place
it'd be it's too big you know there'd be
there's no way you can keep something
like that quiet
as big as something like that
you know
with all the you know all the lawsuits
being shot down one after another that
that was mainly what convinced me
well and and
i think that's very important um and and
we've also talked about today and in
previous hearings
the extent to which the president
himself was told that the election
hadn't been stolen
by his justice department by his white
house counsel by his campaign
would it have made a difference to you
to know that president trump himself had
no evidence of widespread fraud
oh definitely you know
who knows i may not have come come down
here then you know
thank you very much mr chairman i yield
back
young lady yields back chair recognizes
this gentlewoman from florida miss
murphy
thank you mr chairman
you know earlier today we showed how
donald trump's december 19th tweet
summoned both extremist groups as well
as rank and file supporters of president
trump to come to washington d.c
average americans he he told them to
quote be there will be wild and they
came
we showed how mr president
how president trump repeatedly told them
fight fight fight
and they marched to the capitol
um mr ayers you were in that crowd at
the rally and then the crowd that
marched to the capitol
when you arrived on the lips that
morning were you planning on going to
the capitol
no we didn't actually plan to go down
there
um you know went basically to see the
stop to steel rally and that was it
so why'd you decide to march to the
capitol
um well basically uh you know the
president
you know got everybody riled up
told everybody head on down so we
basically just following what he said
after the president's speech as you're
marching down to the capitol how did you
feel
um i was you know
i'm angry
you know after
everything that was
basically said in the speech you know a
lot of stuff he said he already put out
in tweets a lot i've already seen it and
heard it before
um so i mean i was already worked up and
so were most of the people there
so as you started marching did you think
there was still a chance the election
would be overturned
yeah at that time i did um you know
because everybody was kind of like
in the hope that you know vice president
pence was not going to certify the
election
um you know also the whole time on our
way down there he kept hearing about
this big reveal
i remember us talking about and we kind
of thought maybe that was it
so
that that hope was there
did you think that the president would
be marching with you
um yeah i think everybody thought he was
going to be coming down um
you know he said in his speech
you know kind of like he's going to be
there with us
so i mean i think i believed it
i understand
um
we know that you illegally entered the
capitol that afternoon and then left the
capitol area later on what what made you
decide to leave
um basically when president trump put
his tweet out we literally
left right after that come out
um
you know
to me
if he would have done that earlier in
the day
1 30 i you know
you know we wouldn't be in this
maybe we wouldn't be in this bad of a
situation or something
thank you mr chairman i yield back
chair recognizes the gentleman from
maryland mr raskin thank you mr chairman
uh
mr van tatenhoff in the run-up to
january 6 stuart rhodes publicly
implored president trump to invoke the
insurrection act the 1807 law that
allows the president to call up militias
to put down a rebellion
against united states and i want to get
your thoughts about this in the context
of your prior relationship with stuart
rhodes
i understand that
you had conversations with rhodes about
the insurrection act why was he so
fixated on that and
what did he think it would enable the
oath keepers to do
well
i think it gave him a sense of
legitimacy that it was a path forward to
move forward with his goals and agendas
i
i think we need to quit mincing words
and just talk about truths and
what it was going to be was
an armed revolution i mean people died
that day
law enforcement officers died this day
there was a gallows set up in front of
the capitol
this could have been the spark that
started a new civil war and no one
would have won there that would have
been good for no one
he was always looking for ways to
legitimize
what he was doing
whether by
wrapping it in the the trappings of it's
not a militia it's a community
preparedness team
um we're not a militia we're an
educational outreach group it's a
veteran support group
but again we've got to stop with this
this dishonesty and the mincing of words
and just call things for what they are
you know it he
he's a militia leader
he had these grand visions of being a
paramilitary leader
and
the insurrection act would have given
him a path forward with that
you know the the fact that the president
was
communicating whether directly or
indirectly messaging you know kind of
that gave him the nod and
all i can do is thank the gods that
things did not go
any worse
what did the oath keepers see in
president trump
they saw a
path forward that would have legitimacy
they saw opportunity i think in my
opinion
to um
to become a pal para military force
you know
last week the
department of justice
indicated that it has evidence of the
oath keepers bringing not just firearms
but explosives to washington ahead of
january 6th
and the committees also learned that
stewart rhodes stopped to buy weapons on
his way to washington and shipped and
shipped roughly 7 thousand dollars
worth of tactical gear to a january 6
rally planner in virginia before the
attack did you ever hear rhodes discuss
committing violence against elected
political leaders
yeah i mean that went back from the very
beginning of my tenure uh one of the
first assignments that
he brought to me wanting me to do as
more of a graphic artist function was to
create a deck of cards you may remember
back to the the conflict in the middle
east where our own military created a
deck of cards uh which was a who's who
of
kind of the the the key players on the
other side that they wanted to take out
and stewart was very intrigued by that
notion and and influenced by it i think
and he wanted me to create a deck of
cards
that would include different politicians
judges including up to hillary clinton
as the the queen of hearts
um this is a project that i i refuse to
do
but from the very start we saw that
there was always the
the push for military training
um including there were there were there
were courses
in that community
that went over explosives training so
yeah this this all falls in line
mr van tatanov you say in your very
thoughtful written testimony that we
received today that
you fear what the next election cycle
will bring
and you also say that we have been
exceedingly lucky
in that we have not seen more bloodshed
so far i wonder if you would elaborate
on those two statements
i think as far as the luck goes we've
had the potential from bundy ranch on i
mean being boots on the ground at these
these
standoffs and they were standoffs where
there were firearms pointed across lines
at federal law enforcement agencies
um you know whatever it may be with that
particular standoff
but
i do i i think we've gotten exceedingly
lucky that more bloodshed did not happen
because the potential has been there
from the start and we got very lucky
that the loss of life was
and as tragic as it is
that we saw on january 6 the potential
was so much more
again all we have to look at is the
iconic images
of that day with the gallows set up for
mike pence for the vice president of the
united states
you know and and i do fear for this next
election cycle because who knows what
that might bring if if a president
that's willing to
try to
instill and and and
encourage
to whip up a civil war amongst his
followers using lies and deceit and
snake oil
and
regardless of the the human impact
what else is he going to do if he gets
elected again all bets are off at that
point
um and that's a scary notion i have
three daughters i have a granddaughter
and i fear for the world that they will
inherit if we do not start
holding
the these these people to account
thank you for your testimony mr van
tatenhof mr ayers
um
i first want to ask you about
what finally caused you to leave on
january the 6th we know
that the
medieval style combat with our police
the occupation of the building this was
going on for several hours until
the president issued at 417
a tweet i believe that included a video
telling people to go home
did you see that and did that have any
effect on what you were doing
when we were there
as soon as that come out everybody
started talking about it and that's it
seemed like it started to disperse
you know some of the crowd obviously
you know once we got back to the hotel
room we've seen that it was still going
on but it definitely dispersed a lot of
the crowd and did you leave at that
point yeah we did yeah we left
so in other words that was
the key moment when you decided to leave
when president trump told people to go
home yeah we left right when that come
out
um you were not a member of an organized
group like the oath keepers or the proud
boys as most of the crowd wasn't
um
i wonder on january 6th
was it your view that these
far-right groups like the oath keepers
and proud boys and three percenters and
others were on your side did you have
uh
any reservations about marching with
them and rallying with them
well i definitely didn't have a problem
you know
i was probably following them online
myself uh you know i like i thought you
know hey they're on our team good that's
how i kind of looked at it at the time
you know like
i didn't have a problem with it i
thought it was a good thing
i'm interested
in hearing about what's happened to you
since
the events of january 6.
you told the vice chair that you no
longer believe trump's big lie about the
election but that's what brought you
originally to washington
looking back on it now how do you
reflect
on the role that you played in the crowd
that day and what is going on in your
life
um
basically you know i lost my job
this all happened you know uh
pretty much sold my house
um so everything that happened with the
charges you know thank god
uh a lot of them did get dismissed
because i was just holding my phone but
at the same time i was there
um
so i mean it definitely it changed my
life you know uh and not for the good
definitely not for the you know for the
better
um
yeah i mean
well i could say
president trump is still promoting the
big lie about the election
um how does that make you feel
it makes me mad because i
i was hanging on every word he was
saying everything he was putting out i
was following it i mean
if i was doing it hundreds of thousands
or millions
of other people are doing it or maybe
even still doing it
um it's like
he just said about that
you know you got people still falling
and doing that
who knows that the next election could
come out you know
they could end up being down the same
path we are right now i mean
just don't know
um
mr ayers i see that your wife has joined
you today and welcome to washington we
know this has been very difficult on you
both and
your family
what lessons finally do you want the
american people to learn
from the way you and your family
have
suffered as a result of these events
um biggest thing is i consider myself a
family man and i love my country
um
i don't think any one man is bigger than
either one of those
i think that's what needs to be taken
you know
people
dive into the politics
and for me i felt like i had uh you know
like horse blinders on i was i was
locked in the whole time
um biggest thing for me is take the
blinders off make sure you step back and
see what's going on
before it's too late
well i want to thank you for your
testimony and for appearing both of you
today and mr chairman i yield back to
you
gentlemen yields back
i want to thank our witnesses for
joining us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions for today's
witnesses
and we ask that you respond
expeditiously in writing to those
questions
without objections members will be
permitted 10 business days
to submit statements for the record
including opening remarks and additional
questions for the witnesses
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentleman from maryland mr raskin
for a closing statement thank you mr
chairman
when
donald trump sent out his tweet he
became the first president ever
to call for a crowd to descend on the
capital city to block the constitutional
transfer of power
he set off an explosive chain reaction
among his followers but no one mobilized
more quickly than the dangerous
extremists that we've looked at today
seizing upon his invitation to fight
they assembled their followers for an
insurrectionary showdown against
congress and the vice president
on january 6 trump knew the crowd was
angry he knew the crowd was armed he
sent them to the capitol anyway
you might imagine that our founders
would have been shocked to learn that an
american president would one day come to
embrace and excuse political violence
against our own institutions
or knowingly send an armed mob to attack
the capital to usurp the will of the
people
but you know mr chairman the founders
were pretty wise about certain things
and at the start of the republic
they actually warned everyone about
donald trump
not by name of course
but in the course of advising
about the certain prospect that
ambitious politicians would try to
mobilize violent mobs to tear down our
own institutions in service of their
insatiable ambitions in the very first
federalist paper alexander hamilton
observed that history teaches that
opportunistic politicians who desire to
rule at all costs will begin first as
demagogues pandering to the angry and
malignant passions of the crowd but then
end up as tyrants
trampling the freedoms and the rights of
the people
a violent insurrection to overturn an
election is not an abstract thing as
we've heard hundreds of people were
bloodied injured and wounded in the
process including more than 150 police
officers some of them
sitting in this room today
i want to give you an update on one
officer who was badly wounded in the
attack and is well known to the members
of this committee because he testified
before us last year
sergeant aquilina gunnell is an army
veteran who spent a year on active
combat duty in the rock war and then 16
years on the capital force nothing he
ever saw in combat in iraq he has said
prepared him for the insurrection where
he was savagely beaten punched pushed
kicked shoved stomped and sprayed with
chemical irritants along with other
officers by members of a mob carrying
hammers knives batons and police shields
taken by force and wielding the american
flag against police officers is a
dangerous weapon
last month on june 28th
sergeant gunnell's team of doctors told
him
that permanent injuries he has suffered
to his left shoulder
and right foot now make it impossible
for him
to continue as a police officer
he must leave policing for good
and figure out the rest of his life
sergeant gannel
we wish you and your family all the best
we are here for you
we salute you for your valor your
eloquence and your beautiful commitment
to america
i wonder what former president trump
would say to someone like sergeant
cannell who must now go about remaking
his life
i wonder if he could even understand
what motivates a patriot
like sergeant gunnell
in his inaugural address trump
introduced one commanding image
american carnage
although that turn of phrase explained
little about our country before he took
office
it turned out to be an excellent
prophecy of what his rage would come to
visit on our people
mr ayers just described how the trust he
placed in president trump
as a camp follower derailed his life and
nearly wrecked
his reputation in his fi and his family
a few weeks ago we heard shea moss
and her mother ruby freeman
speaker rusty bowers from arizona and
georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger described how hate-filled
intimidation campaigns by trump
and his followers made them prisoners in
their homes
and drove their stress and anxiety to
soaring new heights when they refused to
do trump's bidding
american carnage
that's donald trump's true legacy
his desire to overthrow the people's
election and seize the presidency
interrupted the counting of electoral
college votes for the first time in
american history nearly toppled the
constitutional order and brutalized
hundreds and hundreds of people
the watergate break-in was like a
cub scout meeting compared to this
assault on our people and our
institutions
mr chairman these hearings have been
significant for us and for millions of
americans in our hearing next week will
be a profound moment of reckoning for
america
but the crucial thing is the next step
what this committee what all of us will
do to fortify our democracy against
coups political violence and campaigns
to steal elections away from the people
unlike mr ayres and mr van tatenhof
people who have recovered
and evolved from their dissent into the
hell of fanaticism donald trump has only
expanded his big lie to cover january 6
itself
he asserts the insurrection was the real
election
in the election was the real
insurrection he says his mob greeted our
police officers on january 6 with hugs
and kisses
he threatens to take one of america's
two major political parties with him
down the road to authoritarianism
and it is abraham lincoln's party no
less
the political scientists tell us that
authoritarian parties have two essential
features in common in history and around
the world they do not accept the results
of democratic elections when they lose
and they embrace political violence as
legitimate
and the problem
the problem of incitement to political
violence has only grown
more serious in the internet age as we
have just heard but this is not the
problem of one party it is the problem
of the whole country now
american democracy mr chairman is a
precious inheritance something rare in
the history of the world and even on
earth today
constitutional democracy is the silver
frame as lincoln put it upon which the
golden apple of freedom
rests
we need to defend both our democracy and
our freedom with everything we have and
declare that this american carnage ends
here and now in a world
of resurgent authoritarianism
and racism and anti-semitism let's all
hang tough for american democracy thank
you mr chairman i yield back
gentleman yields back without objection
the chair recognizes the gentlewoman
from florida miss murphy for a closing
statement
thank you mr chairman
at one of our first hearings chairman
thompson explained that the members of
this committee would not spend much time
talking about ourselves rather we would
let the evidence play the leading role
and the chairman was right because this
isn't about promoting ourselves as
individuals it's about protecting the
country we love and it's about
preserving what actually makes america
great the rule of law free and fair
elections and the peaceful transfer of
power from one elected leader to the
next
but if i may say a word about myself and
why i'm proud to serve on this committee
i'm the only member of this committee
who was not blessed to be born an
american
i was born in vietnam after the vietnam
war and my family and i fled a communist
government and were rescued by the u.s
navy and were given sanctuary in america
my patriotism is rooted in my gratitude
for america's grace and generosity
i love this country
on january 6 four decades after my
family fled a place where political
power was seized through violence i was
in the united states capitol fleeing my
fellow americans
members of the angry mob had been lied
to by a president and the other powerful
people who tried to convince them
without evidence that the election had
been stolen from them
some of them then tried to use physical
violence to overturn the outcome of a
free and fair election
our committee's overriding objective is
to fight fiction with facts to create a
full account for the american people and
for the historical record to tell the
truth of what happened and why it
happened to make recommendations so it
never happens again
to defend our democracy
to me
there's nothing more patriotic than that
thank you mr chairman i yield back
general lady yields back without
objection the chair recognizes the
general woman from wyoming miss cheney
for a closing statement thank you very
much mr chairman
mr chairman let me put what you have
seen today in a broader context at the
very outset of our hearings we described
several elements of president trump's
multi-part plan to overturn the 2020
election
our hearings have now covered all but
one of those elements
an organized campaign to persuade
millions of americans of a falsehood
that the 2020 election was stolen by
widespread fraud
a corrupt effort to pressure vice
president pence to refuse to count
electoral votes
an effort to corrupt the u.s department
of justice
efforts to pressure state election
officials and legislators to change
state election results
a scheme to create and submit fake
electoral slates from multiple states
and today you saw how president trump
summoned a mob to washington for january
6th
and then knowing that that mob was armed
directed that mob to the united states
capital
every one of these elements of the
planning for january 6th is an
independently serious matter
they were all ultimately focused on
overturning the election
and they all have one other thing in
common
donald trump participated in each
substantially and personally
he oversaw or directed the activity of
those involved
next week we will return to january 6th
itself
as we have shown in prior hearings
donald trump and his legal team led by
rudy giuliani were working on january
6th to delay or halt congress's counting
of electoral votes
the mob attacking and invading the
capital on that afternoon of january 6th
was achieving that result
and for multiple hours donald trump
refused to intervene to stop it
he would not instruct the mob to leave
or condemn the violence
he would not order them to evacuate the
capitol and disperse
the many pleas for help from congress
did no good
his staff insisted that president trump
call off the attack
he would not
here are a few of the many things you
will hear next week from mr sipoloni
have said others don't was it necessary
for you to continue to push for a
statement directing people to leave
all the way through that period of time
until it was ultimately issued
i felt it was my obligation to continue
to push for that and others felt it was
their obligation as well would it have
been possible at any moment for the
president to walk down to the podium in
the briefing room and
talk to the nation at any time between
when you first gave him that advice two
o'clock in 417 when the video statement
went
would that be possible would it be
possible yes yes
and you will hear that donald trump
never picked up the phone that day to
order his administration to help this is
not ambiguous he did not call the
military his secretary of defense
received no order he did not call his
attorney general
he did not talk to the department of
homeland security
mike pence did all of those things
donald trump did not
we will walk through the events of
january 6th next week minute by minute
and one more item
after our last hearing
president trump
tried to call a witness in our
investigation
a witness you have not yet seen in these
hearings
that person declined to answer or
respond to president trump's call
and instead alerted their lawyer to the
call
their lawyer alerted us
and this committee has supplied that
information to the department of justice
let me say one more time
we will take any effort to influence
witness testimony very seriously
thank you mr chairman i yield back
thank you gentle lady yields back
in my opening i mentioned
how we look to our leaders to serve
as a failed safe if people in this
country
refuse to accept the results of an
election
that's part of the way those and
positions of public trust
uphold their oath
how they show fidelity to the
constitution
in a run-up to january 6th
donald trump had an obligation to tell
his supporters to accept the results of
the election
instead
he urged them to further along
the path toward mob violence
the idea of my violence make me think of
another sort of failed safe
all across this country there are
different ideas about what role the
federal government should play in our
lives
in fact
up here on this dias there are plenty of
different ideas
but there are moments when the
institutions of our federal government
are to fail safe
i am from a part of the country where
had it not been for the federal
government
and the constitution my parents and many
more americans like them
would have continued to be treated as
second-class citizens
the freedom to be able to vote without
harassment
travel and relative safety
and dying and sleep where you choose is
because we have a government
that looks over the well-being of its
citizens
this is especially important
in moments of crisis
when we have a natural disaster that
state governments can't handle on their
own
when there is an emergency that's
requires action by our public health
services or our military
we have a federal government what
happened on january 6 2020
was another one of those moments in
history
that tests the strength of our federal
government
january 6th was an attack on our country
it was an attack on our democracy
on our constitution
a sitting president with a violent mob
trying to stop the peaceful transfer of
power from one president to another
it still makes my blood boil to think of
it
in a moment like that
what would you expect to see
you expect to see the president of the
united states
sitting behind the resolute desk in the
oval office
assuring the american people that the
attack would be repelled
and a threat would be dealt with
you'd expect to be reassured
that there was a fail safe
instead
the president of the united states sent
the mob
he disregarded the advice of the people
who had taken an oath to the
constitution
he oversaw a scheme
aided by people whose loyalty was only
to donald trump
there's nothing we can compare that to
there's nothing in our great nation's
history that has ever come close to that
sort of betrayal in their election
thank goodness
our system of government held in spite
of a commander-in-chief
who worked in opposition to what the
constitution designed
when this committee reconvenes
we'll tell the story of that supreme
dereliction by the commander-in-chief
how close we came to a
catastrophe
for our democracy and how we remain in
serious danger
the chair requests those in the hearing
room remain seated until the capitol
police have escorted witnesses and
members from the room
without objection the committee stands
are joined
and there you have it the committee day
seven has adjourned
the public hearing for the january 6
select committee
big news there at the end
liz cheney always throwing fire
accuses the former president donald
trump
of witness tampering we talked about it
last week as we convened from the
hearing and it looks like we're going to
talk about it again this week um
holy moly i want to remind everyone here
that next week we will be carrying this
hearing as well here on the midas touch
network so please subscribe to the
youtube channel the midas touch network
do not forget to go down and hit the
subscribe button very very important to
stay in tune to the midas touch network
where not only do we carry the hearings
we have the array of podcasts which
i want to lead into that
one of the personalities of the podcast
michael cohen has joined us before uh
michael welcome welcome here michael to
the post hearing coverage we're going to
have some more panelists here but i want
to go to you first because of this
witness tampering
uh allegation that uh is at the end
i know you're probably not surprised by
this we weren't surprised last week when
they started talking about witness
tampering there at the end there were
some text messages that were given but
here today
liz cheney is outright accusing donald
trump
of
tampering with a witness and even the
witness let their attorney know who what
the committee know what what
what gives you this yeah so as i watch
it i'm pretty sure that all the folks
that are now currently um
viewing this live
we're saying the same thing that i was
saying
wow wow and wow i mean let's be serious
about you know what we just saw here and
um
what's going on here
could you imagine had congress done what
they could have and should have done
over two years ago when i testified
before the house oversight committee and
that [ __ ] weasel matt gates was
running around the house oversight
committee room that i was in when i was
testifying live the night before
tweeting out falsehoods about oh wait
till his wife finds out about some
fictitious girlfriend interestingly
enough what we should be noticing is
that everything that was said about me
is a deflection by these folks right
obviously we now know about matt gates
we know about jim jordan we know about
the whole group of them but as i sat and
watched i was saying to myself could you
imagine if they would have gone after
trump for obstruction of justice of
witness tampering over two years ago in
2019 when i testified before the house
all of this would be for naught could
you imagine just how much better as a
country we would be if he just would
have been locked up or or
dismissed or whatever it might have been
that would just put an end to this man's
reign of terror that's all that i just
kept thinking of then i also was
listening to as i mean god blessed benny
thompson and jamie raskin and the the
whole committee i mean that what a job
that they're doing in laying out just
how dirty this trump administration was
and i i will be very honest with you on
this one i'm really so thankful that
this all happened to me in this weird
way because lord knows what he would
have been asking me to do if i was still
within that inner circle i mean that to
me would be the most
damaging thing to this country that i
could imagine that i would be a
participant in so in one respect it's
kind of like a silver lining i'm always
looking for a silver lining in terms of
what happened but then let's talk about
what liz cheney was i'm saying about the
weaponization of the justice department
and how donald trump corrupted the
justice department do we not see that
for example in the unconstitutional
me back to prison and that's just me i'm
talking about let's just look at all of
the various things the pardons that were
given to roger stone or paul manafort
the way that jared kushner was doling
out pardons for cash and for other
things i mean you know we're talking
about the corruption of our justice
department and if we don't have faith in
our justice department i believe
legitimately as a country we're screwed
i i think i think all all good points
with the pardon list and it sounds like
that there may have been a pardon list
um you know the more we dive into this
with some of the testimony today what
did you make of not just the the oath
keeper the former oath keeper who was
more of a character witness to stare
stewart rhodes and the oath keepers
because he wasn't involved with the oath
keepers at the time of the january 6
insurrection but what about the the
actual writer the insurrectionist that
was there what did you make of that well
i i thought it was very unique that the
committee had that person come do you
think that moves the needle at all for
some of these folks out there that still
believe in donald trump or or have the
inclination to no i don't think anything
that's going to happen
they can have a video of donald trump
you know shooting somebody as he stated
on fifth avenue and these same
sycophantic maga you know fools these
manga morons would continue to say the
same stupid thing and they would
continue
to protect or to worship you know donald
trump i mean this is the cult of donald
trump as i talked about in my first book
disloyal but i can't wait for you to end
up getting a you know the copy of my
upcoming book called the department of
injustice it goes exactly into what
we're talking about right now which is
the corruption of the doj based upon you
know a um
a president that doesn't really want to
be president but is jamie raskin so
appropriately put that our forefathers
contemplated that somewhere down the
road that there would be a president
that would want to be more than a
president and then there were certain
safeguards that were put in however what
donald showed this country is that
for every safeguard that's put in
there's a way within which to undo it so
you know look it was a great great
statement by jamie raskin i think the
world of the guy i think he's absolutely
bri i think all of them are doing a
fabulous job on this committee i think
is a historical document
there's probably nothing better that's
going to come out of this you know and
the molar report in order to understand
this trump administration but at the end
of the day now i don't think that it
changes the minds of any of these
die-hard magus supporters and they're
the ones that we have to be careful for
because these are the ones that are
radicalized as that gentleman i think
his name was ayers um was talking about
that they are a paramilitary group you
could call them whatever the heck you
want oath keepers the you know one
percent you can call these guys whatever
the proud boys it doesn't make a
difference what the name of the group is
these people are radical they are um
they are what they could they have many
many weapons they're you know mobilizing
they are now mobilizing through the
internet and other forms trying to stay
under the radar but they are uh military
they're you know they have individuals
that are part of the military so that
they have some tactical experience you
know this is really dangerous we are
really at a danger point in our
democracy in in this country and
i certainly hope that our justice
department i certainly hope that our
president i heard i really hope that our
military are gearing up for what really
i hate to say it could could be
another civil war so let me ask you one
more thing about uh mr ayers and you say
these these these
ulta maga you know supporters the ultra
maga i guess you would call them
you spent time with donald trump even
when he started to gather up these
supporters
does he really like these people does
how does he view these people
what would you what would you tell these
people if they were actually in front of
you
um you know sycophanting for him what
would they tell you how donald trump
views them yeah so the best way to
describe the relationship would be a
chess board they are pawns he certainly
is the king but not only is he the king
he's the queen and he's also you know
your rook um you know he'll allow some
other parts you know the horse in the
castle in order to exist but each and
every one of them all right are all
pawns in his game which is to be
the monarch the dictator right the
supreme leader of the united states
which of course he would change the name
anyway but these people
let me say that he wouldn't walk across
the street to urinate them uh to urinate
on them if in fact they were on fire and
that's what was needed to save their
life he wouldn't step three feet
out of his way in order to do anything
for any of them look he wouldn't do it
for anyone that he's actually close to
right which is truly amazing unless that
there's something
for him unless there's a benefit for him
he is the epitome of a narcissistic
sociopath and that's all that this guy
thinks about when he wakes up and when
he goes to sleep and every second in
between and that's about donald trump
not his wife not his children certainly
not this country not his party all he's
thinking about is himself and how he
could benefit from that opportunity
plain and simple
well and you speak to this as he when he
turns on people because he he did this
with you he's done this with several
other folks
what do you think his relationship with
pat sipoloni is now now that especially
after next week they kind of previewed
some of the the testimony that we might
be seeing on video what do you listen i
i think you're you're
going too far in even thinking about
does he even think about uh pat cipoloni
look at what we saw today
brad parskal
engaging in a telepho a text messaging
with katrina pearson
brad parscal made a ton of money
running the trump website in order to
raise money made a ton of money made
more money in one year than he did in 20
years when he was in private practice as
a social media guy so donald feels that
of course brad owes him
after seeing the text messages between
him and katrina and remember katrina
also became part of the campaign running
around with lara trump and lynn patton
and a whole group of other people you
know based upon the um national
diversity coalition for trump that i
helped to start that i was actually the
founder of
you know he's looking at all of these
people including pat sipoloni including
you know the
mark meadows in his comments everybody
seems to be
pointing the finger
at donald and it's amazing because while
they're all pointing the finger at
donald the only thing including rudy
giuliani and everybody else what donald
is doing is he's saying to himself oh
that's okay
show me one single piece of paper show
me one communication from me to you
other than your hearsay testimony and
then i'll be concerned he's not so
concerned i listen to guys like this
morning i was listening for example to
dan goldman talking about uh you know
this um
evidence that they could possibly use
you know of all of these individuals
pointing their finger at donald and you
know making the allegation that this
could be used in order to um
demonstrate his mens rea his guilty mind
it's not gonna it doesn't work that way
and also remember if this thing goes to
a jury what's the likelihood that
there'll be one person on that jury the
person that will put it into a hung jury
that's not a die-hard trump fan i mean
it's virtually impossible when there are
24
of the republican party that are die
hard you know mega fans it is a ver
we're in a very dangerous situation and
it's why i constantly on may a culpa
when i'm on this program with midas when
i do all of these interviews i keep
begging people make sure you get out to
vote make sure this november and
certainly in the general election that
you're voting straight down the line for
the democrat until this country finally
walks away from trumpism otherwise
restaurant there will be nothing to walk
away from we are at a precipice folks
we're the precipice because donald trump
brought us to the edge of this mountain
and truth be told he'd rather push you
off than you know than to save the
country if that means he is not the
supreme leader this is a
severely
mental
and
deranged human being who has no empathy
for anyone who has no religious
conviction and so all he cares about
again being a narcissistic sociopath is
about himself so if we all do not
mobilize and become a significant
movement in these upcoming elections i
truly believe that our country is is
really headed for um you know headed for
that cliff
well i appreciate it michael thank you
and also go to the minus touch network
while you're here and subscribe
to the youtube channel you will find
michael's podcast maya copa with michael
cohen here on the mind as touch network
thank you michael for joining us stick
around if you can uh friend i i uh we're
going to have a panel i've got to go to
another guest here thanks michael for
joining us
uh so i i'm gonna go to it looks like we
may be
um i'm looking here at some
uh looks like someone may speak i'm
gonna bring in harry lipman while we're
waiting here to see if we have um any
speakers here harry how are you that
nice for you to join us i'm i'm happy to
but but who are we waiting for i'm glad
i can fill in for you but well you know
i'm not i'm not sure who's the main
event that you that you want me to be
there is there is no main event here
sometimes jamie raskin makes his way oh
i've heard of him
yeah he sometimes he makes his way to
the microphone um so i keep a close eye
on the microphone here see we i i do
every i'm the host and i'm i'm watching
the thing and i'm bringing in the guests
but i appreciate you you joining us here
so what is your first take
on the hearing from today
you know i'm again
blown away they they have managed at
each time to up the ante we've kind of
mocked them a little because i guess
they had some professional consulting
help but man oh man how were they going
to top cassidy hutchinson and they did
so i thought they really brought home a
plausible account of just how we got
from the malevolent mind of donald trump
to the melee at the capitol and people
being killed they
you know drew
at least a dotted line and filled a lot
of it uh in made it understandable
really sort of
tore back the curtain and showed us
exactly who was in charge and what they
were doing during those pivotal days and
i find myself as i've been after many of
the hearings kind of thunderstruck
well you know you really called the uh
testimony of cassidy hutches in such an
uh way well in advance before anyone of
what what what would happen after she
would testify um and you were absolutely
correct there because we've seen some of
these dominoes fall not just mark
meadows but now we see patsy bologna
sitting before them and it appears at
the end of the hearing when
liz cheney doesn't only accuse donald
trump of crimes of tampering with
witnesses but she also alludes to the
fact that we're going to hear a lot more
from pat sibolone in next week's hearing
yeah it's going to be tuesday i don't
know if it's going to be tuesday or
thursday but everyone go ahead and
subscribe to the mind as touch network
right here on youtube
tony just gone that big i have no idea
but it would it would be a little bit in
character if the person that he call
that he's calling and trying to
you know actually intimidate is sarah
matthews who's a bit of a cassidy
hutchinson type she quits january 6 from
see she was the deputy press secretary
sat pretty close to all the proceedings
uh and uh she's you know someone if he
tried to browbeat
her it will i think backfire she's gonna
be a very effective witness sorry go
ahead no no i think that's um i think
that's exactly right um we thought she
was going to appear today but they kind
of switched it around on us that's right
they've been very elusive about these
hearings and where they're going with
them where they're not and i don't know
what day we'll get next week but again
everyone stay tuned follow midas touch
on twitter i know you've done some great
videos for midas touch again the one
where you
uh very well called cassie hutchinson as
the key witness here and again the
dominoes fell so having looking back on
that video that you made about cassidy
because i think i think her testimony
has seen those dominoes fall but what do
you expect going forward do you think we
have more than eight hearings do you
think they continue this because of the
because of more evidence pouring in of
people maybe protecting themselves with
criminal liability you're the attorney
you tell me yeah well so the next one
was designed to be kind of the
culminating set piece that's how trump
spent these 184
minutes while the riot raged he's he's
anywhere from you know jubilant to to uh
contemptuous of of the people who are
cowering and you know worried about
being killed as some people uh were i
think we have at least after that
estimation hearing but maybe one other
as well by all accounts information is
flooding into them but i today's hearing
just went
so so close home
we you know i'd heard well everything
happened in this december 18th meeting
and it seemed like really you're gonna
tie it all to that but this was not a
your normal meeting six hours of people
screaming at each other
and you know look here's my basic
feeling tony about today
there are there are ragtag
uh conspiracy theorists in the world
there are you know half-lives and and
and little lives uh in the world
um and that and we saw them here today
but they but what happened is everybody
and this wasn't clear before the
hearings every grown-up in the room told
trump there's nothing to be done here so
he just cast about until he could find
and look at this look at this crew of
scoundrels powell flynn giuliani and
then stuart rhodes and he and the
hearing today made a really conclusive
showing that these were the people he
summoned these were the people actually
exercising presidential power
for um
you know at two three very pivotal days
and these were the people who really
endangered the life of his vice
president so they were it was almost
like a a um you know crazy pickeresque
novel or something but then you just had
to remember
they're they're here and playing a role
on the stage because trump at his wit's
end and out of options has empowered
them to do it i've prosecuted guys like
this they're around but that they should
be uh ex you know doing the bidding of
the president of the united states
that's the remarkable point of this
story and that means it really does go
back to donald trump
well it was it's a very weird american
history story
that that people are walking into a
meeting where the president's sitting
with the ceo or the former ceo of
overstock trying to figure out how to
constitutionally overturn the election
of the united states that was the free
is the most fairest election that even
bill barr said the idea that something
was stolen is absolutely [ __ ] was
his was his words um even watching more
tape from him today and a former gu as a
former government in person i can just
tell you the fact of that meeting junior
staffers escorting them into the white
house and letting them in you can well
understand why pat sipoloni in powell's
in in sydney powell's words said a land
speed record it's
holy [ __ ] what's happening that is
absolutely something the chief of staff
cannot permit to happen it shows meadows
being either feckless or kind of in on
the on the whole um ruse or or
conspiracy so just that it starts that
way is one thing and then what
transpires thereafter six hours and just
a few minutes later he sends that big
tweet i found it a pretty persuasive
case that he had ignored all the
grown-ups gone with team crazy and was
implementing their plan right away and
it was in fact accepted by the the
terrorists who came on the sixth as a
call to arms he he meant it that way
they took it that way well the lady was
who who kept saying release the crack
and uh we know now sydney powell she was
one of the influencers and you know some
of the deposition tape of her
still in this mindset it just it's a
it's it's amazing to me that here we are
she's sitting before the select
committee um being deposed about the
election being overturned by the
president where she was giving this
this delusional advice this delusional
constitutional advice i guess you'd call
it and here she is still in this mindset
um
sipping a dr pepper and yeah having a
good arrogant uh disparaging of all the
real officials again people like that
exist in the world that they exercise
the power and will of the present that's
crazy um i don't know how much time you
have tony but can i tell you one other
big revelation today go ahead yeah
please okay so so fine they you know he
pushes and gets pence mentioned in there
that's already scandalous but i i was um
really struck that then he goes to the
rally and ad lives and what's the ad lib
seven mentions of pence to get them
revved up about this
you know nothing about the peacefully
the line that was inserted in there to
give him deniability everything he does
is really and truly intended to rev them
up into a murderous intense rage that
they would have torn the vice president
lim from lim and i think we're going to
find out at this final hearing as all of
this is you know as dc is burning he
he's laughing he won't you know he won't
put out a tweet and when he finally does
he says go home we love you you know
this is this is really a diluted kind of
you know complete takeover by the
by by domestic terrorists except again
it's abetted by the president of the
united states domestic terrorists are
out there they don't get to do the
bidding of the president well i
appreciate you pointing that fact out as
well harry
man please please plug your your podcast
as we sit here oh well that's very kind
so talking feds
uh which uh i we've uh we do week in
week out with some really great guests
jamie raskin often among them but you
know we're really proud of the sort of
round table i think you'd only see
people like that on sort of sunday shows
and even then it'd be for sound bites
these are sort of pretty rich
discussions so thanks a lot tony for
serving it up no problem and and also
subscribe to the minus touch network
where harry appears yeah uh in in great
videos in his reflection for them yeah
in his great crystal ball of knowing
that cassidy hutchinson
reactions and predictions all right
that's right thank you very much harry
thanks for joining us all right see you
tony
uh harry litman there um we're going to
bring in our panel i have jessica denson
uh david bender and texas paul with us
right now and i'd like to get i think
david uh actually had something to build
on with i'm still watching to see if
we're gonna have someone come to the
microphone but i think david actually
had something to build on with the uh
mike pence that uh um david did you have
something you wanted to build on there
it's interesting to hear you know uh pat
cipolloni talking about
uh
you know
mike pence deserving a medal of freedom
from the president how much he admired
the strength of mike pence
there's reporting and i think it might
be uh robert costa's book i can't
remember where but
when the rift happened
after pence did what he did
held strong
there were there were still another two
weeks
and they weren't speaking and there was
a desire to try and get them back
together
so
there was an effort to get
trump to give mike pence the
presidential medal of freedom a way of
somehow healing this rift because people
felt it was
important that that happened
so he thought about it and he gave the
presidential medal of freedom
to jim jordan
so
there's there's a lot of subtext about
what's going on here cibolone's saying
that made me remember that that was the
real life circumstance that was going on
rather than try and
rise above it and heal this rift and and
have his loyal vice president back in
the fold
he doubled down triple down which as
jessica well knows this is what he
always does right well i wanted to go to
jessica to get her take on not only um
the second half of the hearing here but
at the very end when liz cheney seems to
burn down the house of trump and give
him a very stark warning here that hey
we know you're you're still criming and
stuff
what do you what do you make of it
jessica
yeah and it was referred or the doj was
notified which um
here we go doj i mean what else do we
need to see i i again was very
um
moved and agitated by these very uh
visceral
accounts of people's lives being
materially altered um we saw uh the
to to sergeant um go now because i'm
saying his name on ganell i believe at
the end of um at the end of the hearing
from raskin he's no longer going to be
able to serve as an officer because of
the injuries he sustained on january 6th
the american carnage that donald trump
has caused just runs through every fiber
of our society and continues
as this man is free
uh these two witnesses stephen ayers and
jason van tatenhove
i'll start with steven ayers we heard
some commentary earlier that said this
cult will never break there's no
extraction from the cult that's not true
if that were true about any human
being living on this planet we would
cease to live okay our very existence is
a sign of hope and redemption so there
is an opportunity for these cult members
to come out from their brainwashed um
sheltered um you know
blinded lives and come to the truth and
it is a it is a very um
tattered route as this steven airs
individual shared okay his luck he is
now a convicted felon
because of the lies of donald trump that
he believed and what did this man do
after the testimony today he went and
hugged those officers and apologized to
them he apologized to them this is the
healing this is this is the effect of
justice this is what justice does
justice is not political recognition
justice is healing justice is wholeness
justice is is progress and fulfillment
and and peace
that's what justice is merit garland doj
that is what we need you to bring
right now to our country so that we can
have a future that we can live in
um jason van tatenhove i i really i knew
before this hearing that i was gonna
like this man um i really related to him
so much
he said uh towards the end um liz cheney
asked him what got you out of out of
this circle of the oath keepers and he
described being in a grocery store
and how his family was basically so
um
poor i mean they just they did not they
did not have money this this is just
goes to show how disgusting these
criminal elites like donald trump are
they prey on people who have nothing in
this world they use the people that are
most desperate and wanting for any
feeling of belonging or purpose or
anything which manifests itself in all
of these horrible manifestations like
racism and white supremacy and all of
these other manifestations of evil but
ultimately
these people are looking for a place to
belong and they prey on the most
desperate people
and this jason van taten hopefully it
was so it was so
touching to see what he said he said
because when i walked away i did not
know where i was going
i did not know
and i re and it it was so relatable to
me because when i saw the trump campaign
i had no idea where i was going with it
i had no idea where it was going to
bring me but i knew it was the right
thing to do
and this man has taken what he knows and
he has put his knowledge and pain to
purpose and he is trying to
warn people he said in his testimony
today he said
talked about the consequences if we do
not hold these people to account
he said before it's too late we must do
something when i first warned the
country about the dangers of donald
trump when i woke up from this madness
this delusion
it was in february of 2019 it was about
a week before cohen's testimony to
congress i went on television for the
first time on cnn i was living under the
threat
of a fifty thousand dollar judgment for
violating donald trump's campaign
illegal non-disclosure agreement i had
just found out that i lost this this
bogus arbitration that was brought
against me and they were moving into
court state and federal to confirm a 50
000 award against me that would have
bankrupted me i had no money i couldn't
pay but the one thing i had was my
credit the one thing i had and if i had
had to face that that judgment
enforcement which they tried to
carry out even as i was fighting it i
would have lost the one thing that i had
and
in even with that pressure without a
book to sell i came on television and i
warned the american people i said we are
in a very dangerous time in our country
we need all hands on deck to confront
the oppression and the lies coming out
of the man who's supposed to be the free
world and before
it's
too
late
so much damage has happened between
february of 2019 and today it has
happened between january 6 2021 and
today
no more time for inaction we must stop
this american carnage
now i'm glad you brought it to that
point because um we
watched as
jamie raskin so well put uh take take
took the words right out of
trump's mouth from his original
inauguration speech where
he so dumbly referred to the country
with american carnage at that time and
now
now we are living with the american
carnage as you describe it uh texas paul
um give me what your take was from the
testimony of the two witnesses in the
second half of this hearing
and how how do you see do you see you
know i ask michael moving the neato and
jessica she obviously knows that this is
in uh you know we are in defcon 5 here
um but what do you think do you think
this moves the needle at all texas ball
for who well i mean you know we're
looking at a situation where we're
trying to convince certain americans
of what the truth is like jessica said
you come out of this this delusion this
hypnotic delusion of what trump is what
it isn't what the what the country is
what it isn't i mean we've watched
people uh embrace this christian
nationalism as jessica so well put it
it's a non-christian nationalism because
it has nothing to do with uh the
the new testament whatsoever
what what do you make do you think do
you think those testimonies from
totenhaven and ayers do you think that
wakes some folks up who are still in
this delusion michael cohen doesn't seem
to believe it but what about you
every every one of these hearings we
peel off a few more we do and i gotta
and i gotta say something
you know i i tell it straight the way it
is whether it's to my people or
republicans or whoever i don't lie i
followed the chat
while those two guys were testifying and
i gotta tell you people i'm a little
sick to my stomach i don't mean to you
know to chew your ass or anything like
that but if it had been the
david caress cult if it had been the
warren jeff's cult if it had been the
reverend moon cult if it had been any
any other damn cult in the world that
these people left y'all wouldn't have
been [ __ ] all over these two guys
like you were i got to tell you
something as people leave the maga cult
and it's a goddamn cult
it is it's a cult 100
i mean look at what stone was preaching
the night before i told you palin same
damn thing good versus evil light versus
dark they've anointed
you know trump to be the god's chosen
it's a damn cult and if you had anybody
else leaving any other cult you would
not [ __ ] on them when they left you
would be helping them and that's what
i'm asking you to do i hate republicans
more than anybody i do i swear to god i
despise those sons of [ __ ] but you
know when somebody gets out of a cult
you don't crap on them okay let's just
let's not do that anymore please i'm
begging you i'm begging you but you know
can i make a more important point than
that go ahead paul if you followed if
you followed what we just saw
i mean it it's the night before you had
like i said stone like you know
all his his speech with good and evil
light and dark to set in the other you
had mike lindell tweeting out don't give
away the second part the second part is
the important part you give away the
second part and you know the more boys
are getting our way he was talking about
ship alone and i guarantee you he was
talking he was talking talking about
hershman he was talking about the people
that the grown-ups in the room you can't
give it away folks then
trump wakes up been in a bad mood for
weeks and all of a sudden man his feet
can't touch the floor he's happy as can
be he's excited he's ready to go and
then he has a conversation with pence
and he's all pissed off ivanka lies
under trump lies under oath says that
she's not there to calm trump down
uh you know and we know trump
immediately changed his speech as soon
as he got off the phone he said put this
[ __ ] back in the speech and he was
hateful as hell he rap he route he
rallied those people up on purpose and
sent them down to the damn capital and
i i you know i hate to say this but
you know i'm the only thing i'm afraid
of i'm i'm not afraid of a whole hell of
a lot but one thing that does make me
afraid and i'm a huge biden supporter is
that right now this country
needs a teddy roosevelt
we do when teddy roosevelt came into
office the the federal government was
corrupt as hell and right now we need a
teddy roosevelt to take a look at what's
going on in our
justice department what's going on
within all the departments of our
government and this cult has to be
rooted out in the state of new york they
just uh had their uh handgun laws
overturned and it was a be careful what
you wish for situation because the new
law that they put forward they go back
and they look at all your social media
before you can get a permit
that's the kind of [ __ ] that needs to be
happening
they need to be rooting through this
government person to person to person
and finding out who is a traitor who is
in this cult because people in this cult
that will not put the constitution
before god anointed donald trump need to
be kicked the hell out of this
government 100
and that's the only thing that scares me
is that joe biden is one hell of a deal
maker he is he's a he's a he's a co you
know common sense let's get things done
been in the senate for 40 years deal
maker and right now we need somebody
that's going to grab the eagle shove it
down in that bathtub and hit it with a
scrub brush i'm telling you
now texas ball always has a way of
saying things i i got another guest i
want to bring in here uh representative
mike malcolm kenyatta
malcolm how are you um how are you sir
well i'm like fangirling
good no good good to see you all um i
will tell you like like the entire
country i'm kind of reeling from from
from watching these hearings you know
it's one thing to
to to know this information i feel like
everybody who has been paying attention
um since the attack on january 6 you
know understands that the president was
involved that folks like rudy giuliani
were involved that somehow the my pillow
guy was involved apparently the
overstock guy was was involved so we
kind of knew some of the pieces of it
but to see it laid out as thoroughly as
methodically as chairman thompson and
the committee are laying it out
it draws into stark relief
how close
we came to losing this entire experiment
in democracy and frankly i leave this
hearing after seeing that bevy of
evidence
incredibly frustrated that the
department of justice and that the fbi
um has not somehow found their way to
mar-a-lago i don't know if it's an issue
of getting directions to where
mar-a-lago is
but the evidence is clear here that you
have a guy who's no longer sitting in
the oval office but who is still engaged
in crimes this time in terms of witness
tampering so that the american people
can't understand the full extent of the
planning the preparation um and the
engagement that the president had um in
coordinating this attack in january on
january 6.
so malcolm you represent the 181st in uh
in pennsylvania and in your state the
big lie was uh you were targeted the
state was targeted by the big lie and
even republicans now still to this day
are are pushing that big lie even in
your legislator not just to try to
spread it um just as as far and as wide
as they can you gave a speech the other
day that kind of went viral um
about at your state legislator about the
uh ban on abortion
and the overturning of roe v wade so
tell folks because you're in this fight
in the actual policy realm right we're
not just talking about the politics of
it you're down there making policy as a
state legislator in pennsylvania so tell
us
what is at stake
you know tony i've been in the thick of
this for for a while now um i actually
was which was chosen by president biden
vice president harris um to be one of
the electors um and
my
republican members of the house actually
sued us when they talk about all of
those lawsuits one of the lawsuits was
to try to keep the electors in
pennsylvania from actually going and
fulfilling our ceremonial but critical
uh duty of confirming who the next
president and vice president will be
through the electoral college process my
colleagues literally sued me
and sued others to try to stop us from
doing that i am the democratic chair of
our subcommittee on campaign finance and
elections under the powerful house state
government committee one of the most
powerful committees in the in harrisburg
in part because the name sort of lays it
out um we oversee all state functions
including elections and i have been
since
2020
fighting an ongoing continuous battle to
stop my republican colleagues from not
only lying about the last election but
from using their authority to try to
make it easier for them to cheat the
next time
that you know video which went viral
you know everybody was focused on the
the abortion piece
of of that constitutional amendment but
i called that amendment a crap sandwich
because it was actually multiple layers
of what they wanted to do in that
constitutional amendment not only did
they want to effectively ban abortion
they also wanted to allow our auditor
general who's a republican elected
official who also doesn't accept the
results of the elections they want to
put him in charge of auditing all future
elections they want to have radical um
voter id on top of the voter id that
pennsylvania already has and so this is
a part of a concerted effort and
pennsylvania is very much in the thick
of it well i appreciate you joining us
and i know you're on limited time here
um but what can folks do what in reality
because i know you're doing your best
on those subcommittees and i know
democrats around the country and the
state legislators because i think we
kind of
get our eye off the ball when we talk
about these federal elections when these
elections happen in the states that's
where the policy happens so what but
what can folks really do if they're not
a elected representative what can they
do tell me what is the power of the
ballot that they actually have
so first let me say thank you to you and
to into your panel because you are
helping to educate folks on how they can
be involved and that's an important part
of this process you know in in 2010 if
folks haven't listened to the episode of
the daily um from from yesterday the the
7-eleven episode of the daily it talked
about the methodical way in which
republicans went about building power in
state legislatures that ultimately led
to the overturning of roe and now 20
plus states that have effectively banned
abortion on their way to banning
abortion we have to as people who care
about preserving democracy
as democrats or as democratically
aligned independents
we have to do everything we can to
refocus this conversation on where this
battle is actually being fought there
are folks who went to that insurrection
who are now running for state office
doug mostriano i call him insurrection
doug
is the republican nominee for governor
he was at the insurrection he brought
down multiple busloads of people from
pennsylvania um he is
on track
to
continue to be a clear and present
danger if we do not stop him and make
sure josh shapiro becomes our next
governor but i also want to outline this
for folks who are listening to your
program we can win
the state house in pennsylvania
republicans have controlled it for 30
years for 30 years but we can win it now
in this election 23 different um
incumbent republicans retired and so we
only need to pick up 12 seats
and when i look at you know some of the
money that these national candidates you
know raise i'm happy because we do need
to pick up seats in the u.s senate but
also it's a little frustrating because
if you're a state house member and you
get just one quarter where you raise a
hundred thousand dollars or a quarter of
a million dollars
that can put you over the the finish
line in a serious way in a tough
contested race and so you know i ran
hard for for for u.s senate talked about
what's at stake for working families and
i want to drive this point home that
winning in the u.s senate critical
making sure jon fetterman becomes our
next u.s senator critical i'm doing
everything i can to make that happen
josh shapiro critical but for folks who
are watching
please go to my go to my uh my twitter
page and my pen tweet is a link to that
viral their viral speech but it's also a
link for folks to get involved in pa
htcc which is the house democrats
campaign committee we need to win these
seats these 12 seats if not
if not the same folks who we saw at the
insurrection are going to be in charge
in harrisburg and they're going to be
able to decide who can vote and who
can't vote they're going to be able to
decide whether or not the republican
auditor general um can go out and give
some credence to the lies that donald
trump and his acolytes have continued to
tell about elections um and about the
future of our country and so thank you
thank you to your panel and i just
encourage everybody get involved in your
local states if you got if you got just
a few minutes i think david bender here
has question
a question for you uh representative uh
uh like uh jessica big fan uh you ran a
great campaign and i'm glad to hear that
uh you're doing everything you can for
uh
senator we hope betterment
let me uh let me ask you a question a
couple of questions one is uh
you were an elector there were a group
of fake pennsylvania electors who signed
certificates is there any effort to
prosecute them at the state level is
there anything that can be done there
with attorney general maybe hopefully
governor soon shapiro what's happening
there
so i think uh the attorney general has
spoken on this um that at least here
with the fake electors it didn't get as
far in the process as some of the other
states um which have been mentioned
during during these hearings and so some
of the folks who've been involved in
this effort um you know may have come a
little short of actually breaking any
any any crimes even though they were
well on their way and so um you know i
don't i have not heard of on any
hearings um excuse me of any
investigations rather and to that beyond
um what i just related from the from the
attorney general um at this point and
and and to your previous point it's
funny that you brought up because i was
just having a conversation with a group
of people here in california about the
importance of the pennsylvania state
legislature
uh
it's 12 seats in the assembly am i
correct it's five seats in the
pennsylvania senate if they fly um i
believe we need it we need a few more in
the senate and i'm always gonna be
honest with with people flipping the the
pennsylvania senate i think is gonna be
really tough um and i think the way the
map is is composed right now i don't
know if that's possible next year i
think it's possible maybe two years from
now flipping the pennsylvania state
house
is exceedingly possible it is more than
it is more than doable and we're in a
position where we could stop a lot of
bad things if we had a few more seats um
in the state house a lot of bad things
well i'm gonna i'm gonna say i've been
encouraging people to look at
pennsylvania specifically for that
reason because it's going to be so
crucial uh in 24.
and we know
you you just identified it people going
to your uh
website but the pennsylvania hdcc is the
fund that you're trying to get people to
support is that correct that's right
that's the pennsylvania house uh
democratic campaign committee um you
know and people can just just you know
just look that up as well and see some
of the some of these tough races where
you have folks who are in d plus one d
plus four you know districts those are
winnable districts right those are tough
districts those are um
going to be districts that we're going
to have to work really hard in but
here's the good news we have some
incredible candidates um who are running
um all up and down the ballot
i have been supporting those candidates
you will see me
doing a lot of travel um around the
commonwealth supporting those candidates
using the platform you know that i've
that i've built to try to you know put
some spotlight on some of these
candidates who i think people ought to
pay attention to you know kathy sparr in
chester county did an event for her
right after i got back from from
vacation after losing the senate race
got right back on the horse and was out
there for for kathy sparr who can flip a
seat of somebody who signed that letter
to throw out the votes there you go
you know so that really
these are the elections and that's
that's the advantage it's a very bad
year
to be a republican in pennsylvania
because you've got maustriano at the top
of the ticket uh
you know with dr oz who doesn't live in
the state it's not a good year to be
republican all the way down ballot so i
i agree with you i think that this is a
chance really to make a difference for
people outside your state to help and
i'm going to encourage that david i
think we should make this the worst year
to be a republican uh jessica did you
want to ask representative malcolm
kenyon is something before he before he
hops out of here
as i said
huge fans so delighted to see you here
i'm so um i'm so appreciative of your
drawing of attention to local and state
races
there is not a race in this country that
your vote does not matter in um as
representative kenyatta is saying
pennsylvania is so vital i mean we can
just go down the list arizona michigan
wisconsin georgia i mean
even in california just 30 miles up the
road there's a swing race there is not a
single race in this country where you if
you are eligible to vote will not make a
difference so
realize the power that you have at this
in this moment in history um
as work this panel is all saying the
urgency could not we could not have
a greater threshold of urgency and role
to play in saving our democracy from the
fascist forces the minority rule that is
threatening to undermine our freedom and
our future so you know get engaged
donate to
organizations democratic organizations
like representative kenyatta is um is
sharing they need all of our help this
is the moment this is the time for us to
do this thank you make one more final
point before absolutely before i go
the good news i think especially here in
pennsylvania for the state house
candidates who i know are running
yes this is in some ways a defensive
vote right and a defensive cycle for all
the reasons that jessica just ably um
laid out there really are fascists at
the door who could win these seats and
would do everything in their power to
ban abortion to make it more harder to
vote to you know treat trans kids like
political football they're gonna do all
that stuff but i hope people also feel
inspired by the fact that this is also
an offensive vote as well the candidates
who are running in these races they are
small business owners they are just moms
who decided to step up and run they are
community activists they are lawyers
they are faith leaders these are people
who you can be excited about candidates
who aren't just going to do the bare
minimum of you know protecting our
democracy which we must do but
candidates who are going to be about
advancing an agenda that lifts up
working people and that's what always
gets me excited when i can you know vote
for somebody to stop something bad but
also vote for somebody who i know is
going to make a difference for working
people and for families and
neighborhoods like mine and i think that
that's what's at stake as well on an
agenda that lifts up working people
because the fascist minority party does
not care about working people okay these
the same people who are aligned with the
koch brothers and all these big business
that is who they are in it for a very
very small group the candidates who are
running in these races are people who
are going to stop um this assault
against our democracy but they're also
then going to be able to advance an
agenda that lifts up working families
and i get excited about that
representative kenyatta give us one last
time where we can go where the audience
can go to um to find you on twitter and
and the links that you're talking about
yup i'm at malcolm kenyatta everywhere
if you look at my my pinned uh my pen
tweet it goes right to a link of pa htcc
and encourage folks to um to donate
right there we're gonna win in
pennsylvania and we're gonna be a part
of saving our democracy just like we did
a couple of years ago well thank you for
joining us and and if you scroll down
that twitter feed long enough you'll
probably run into that viral video so
you can you can find him there thank you
thank you representative for joining us
thank you for joining us here
what what a great guest i'm going to
bring in gabe um the
executive producer extraordinaire and my
co-host on our podcast the tony michaels
podcast go follow us over on our youtube
channel speaking of that just type in
the tony michaels podcast follow us
there on on the tubes of you and also
while you're here hit the subscribe
button on the midas touch network we're
going to have a great hearing next week
it seems i want to talk about the
hearing that we just had but i am i'm
i'm already in the next game
folks i'm already in the next game
because i want to see what pat cipoloni
said i want to know who the witness that
donald trump was tampering with i
already want to know these things and
liz cheney does such a good job and the
committee has done such a good job to
lay the hook on the american people to
keep them watching these hearings
because i think that's so important and
i i know i know it seems dramatic at the
very end for liz cheney to really burn
down donald trump's house um as maybe
texas paul would say without pissing on
the ashes just letting it smolder
for another week or so but really
i i believe that that is to hook us and
to hold us what do you think gabe what i
haven't had you on much because we've
been so busy here with them yeah we i
mean we've had some we have a great
guest today too but i think i think uh
from just a production standpoint like
you you have to you have to understand
that we just came from a few weeks of a
break right so you're you're it's more
or less starting from scratch again we
had a huge turnout of people that were
viewing the first night the the prime
uh the prime time evening and now we're
coming back after a little bit of break
we had the holidays we've had a lot of
other stuff that's kind of hit the fan
just in news in general and now we're
trying to get people's attention back
which we already know that everyone has
a short attention span
so from a production standpoint
you got to make sure that the next one
out of the gate which was this one is
more or less pretty juicy right it's
spicy it's got something to it that
people can splice can do sound bites can
share can tweak and hashtag whatever
right like people are already making
jokes about how much how many gallons of
ketchup are already on the walls of
mar-a-lago right these are things that
people are talking about because they're
very effective at what they've done from
a production standpoint and i think this
goes to show you that the following ones
as they tease them out like it's a show
and this is the season next week on the
insurrection you find out whatever right
last week on the insurrection you found
out whatever right and this week again
it's another one of these like who shot
jr moments
which is we want to know who this person
is that that that trump was tampering
with is he even old enough
i am i know i know the reference
nice historical reference right yeah
yeah
so david david give us a sense there too
isn't there uh
texas ball well david give us give us a
sense of what you think next week will
bring um what do
it wasn't exactly that we
this has been the most nimble
of of television shows if you think
about it and it's being produced
amazingly by a man who used to run abc
news good morning america at nightline
and he's a brit
so
the irony of our democracy being saved
by
the state people we broke away from is
not lost on me
but if you think about what they had to
do
they didn't know until fourth the fourth
deposition of cassidy hutchinson
that they needed to put her on the air
the fourth time they set her down they
realized this needs to go on and it
needs to go on quickly
because she can be intimidated
so they kept it private as long as they
could remember it didn't break until i
think tony you and i were texting back
and forth yes it was very late right it
was like before harry harry litman was
one of the only ones that really thought
that cassie hutchinson would even come
into the forefront which is exactly
right
and and you know we we understand that
the security of the witnesses including
some of the people who you know were
there today imagine what it's like to be
uh
a former oath keeper or to to be a man
who has you know is on trial and is
about to be sentenced for was on trial
and convicted
uh he's gonna get more threats
and it's no surprise i i do think the
fact that trump is making calls
personally shows
just how desperate he is and how much
attention he's paying but to the point
of what's going to happen next week and
what happened today what happened today
is was informed by a deposition they got
on friday
the patsy bologna was in there for eight
plus hours on friday today is tuesday
they had to work with all of that
material and figure out how to cut it
together which is why i think we don't
have a hearing again
uh the day after tomorrow they needed
more time to work out this final tick
tock
so what's going to happen next week the
date tbd could be a week from today
could be a little longer we'll know
uh is that we're going to see
that's more of patchapoloni but we're
going to see the 187 minutes i believe
it is the dereliction of duty this was
marshalling the mob if each of these
episodes has a title
uh in next on insurrection it will be
dereliction of duty
and and what what does that mean it
means that
some of the witnesses we already know
we've seen them uh pat sabloni
definitely is going to talk about what
he wished the president would pay
attention to
we've heard yet again and now
it's being pieced together mark meadows
not only was he not a gatekeeper and
keeping out
sydney powell and keeping out the pillow
guy and the overstock guy
he may have been having a meltdown he
may really have been paralyzed and
that's some of what cassidy hutchinson
was was sort of implying
yeah mark get off your phone this is
happening in real time people
and pat cipollone's line which he didn't
contradict
is you know this is crazy
uh and
more to the point i think he was quoted
as saying you know people there's gonna
be
blood on people's hands
and there was so what will we see on
next week
we don't know that's the whole point
right
tuning in there's a witness that's been
threatened and we haven't even
identified that person yet and it's
clear it's someone we don't know well i
was going to go to someone with a cowboy
hat on but i have someone waiting in the
wings that may or may not jessica have a
cowboy hat on um and i want to get maybe
his legal thoughts of what next week
could bring in the witness tampering at
the end uh ben my zealous here have
legally having the mice this is bottom
row
the hat row there uh ben what did you
what did you make because i really i i'm
hanging on the hook here like i've
almost forgot what what the hell this
hearing was about because the hook of
the witness tampering where you you know
you know that the cheeto dust mobster as
i refer to him the the the former
president uh donald trump the former guy
he has to
know exactly what liz cheney knows and
liz cheney wanted him to know that she
knows what he's done so what do you what
did you make of that ending there
we've always compared
trump to a mafia boss and in many ways
the presentation is a presentation
against
a mafia leader and
because the mafia's inner circle you
know often isn't forthcoming um the way
mafia bosses ultimately go down are
often for you know tax related charges
or obstruction
threatening
witnesses is a common tactic of the
mafia boss and the despot and that's
really what we see here you know you
could be sure
you know it seemed they were obviously
talking about sarah matthews although we
don't know that for a fact but that's
who it sounded like they were uh talking
about and the deputy press secretary to
trump how significant how heavily that's
weighing in trump you then compare that
to all of his just completely
batshit crazy messages even more batshit
crazy messages than before kind of
coming out of his social media and
what's going on in the rallies and you
really see someone spiraling you also
compare that with the new york times
pull out today that about 50 percent of
republicans voting in the primaries no
longer support him and this is someone
who is spiraling and spiraling because
of the work of the january 6th committee
exposing him it was not a foregone
conclusion that it was going to go down
this way and it's a lesson to everybody
listening out there and watching that
you know you can't just be a passive
actor in a democracy you have to be an
active player and people make the change
don't let the change right into the
people and that's what we see with the
january 6th committee and and the work
that they're doing and
just want to also mention this before we
go to our great panel everybody who's
watching this now please make sure you
subscribe to the midas touch youtube
channel hit that subscribe button right
now turn notifications on for all of the
updates all the breaking news and of
course this incredible uh show by tony
michaels gabe sanchez and this great
panel with jessica texas paul dave
bender and others and thanks so much
everybody for the hard work you're all
put into this
well i i i so so you're not going to
stay on hat row you're going to you're
going to leave it is that what you're
doing no no i'm definitely going to stay
with you okay great great yeah stay on
hat row for a minute jessica did you
want did you have something you wanted
to follow up on the uh the mafia line
because then i want to go to the other
the other hat that we have down there
texas ball uh to see if he has any
thoughts what do you got there jessica
your your mic is muted
there we go
okay yeah um i used to i i've long
thought along these lines that ben is
talking that trump is like a mob boss
and and i was watching there's this
amazing show out right now called the
offer it's about the making of the
godfather um the already story already
was the producer
and
i was reminded as i watched the story
and then watching the godfather
afterwards happened to be the first time
i ever watched the godfather which is
shocking um
that that
trump doesn't even deserve the privilege
of being compared to the mob like even
the mob as
vicious and brutal as they are better
than trump because
they they at least have a code of
loyalty and they don't hurt people
unless they cross the line into their
their realm donald trump hurts everyone
he hurts people within his realm he
hurts people on the outside as i said
earlier in this panel his campaign was
and is and always was a campaign of mass
destruction but there's this great line
um in the godfather that that just
stuck out to me so much
by um the character clemenza one of the
one of the mafia guys he says he's
talking about you know their their
rivals their their mafia rivals and he
says you know you got to stop them in
the beginning like they should have
stopped hitler in munich they should
have never let him get away
away with that they were just asking for
big trouble so it just
you know brings it back to where we are
right now we are in a historical moment
that is um that is going to bring us
into so much further trouble
if we do not hold donald trump
accountable right now um i know
there the there's been a waning of
public attention on ukraine but i i
really hope that we do not
lose lose sight of the global picture
that we're dealing with um
there there was a clip on russian media
a few weeks ago where
where one of the russian commentators
said
we haven't decided yet if we're going to
install trump as president again
and that is who we are dealing with in
this country we're dealing with putin's
party parading as
a legitimate um political arm in
american politics and their their
intentions are are very bad
well i i you you say that uh maybe we
shouldn't uh give him the uh
the title mafia boss because he's not as
good i always call them they're nazis
but they're nin kapoop nazis like these
are ninca poops that we're dealing with
right open zeros yeah right exactly
exactly they don't understand they're
the baddies they are the baddies but
they are ninca poops because if they
were smart if they did know how to
you know instrument a coup we may be in
real trouble maybe we wouldn't even be
sitting here talking texas paul give us
your thoughts on the ninja poop nazis as
it were um we're all dying to hear the
texas paul take
okay republicans suck and people are
sick of their [ __ ]
i'm telling you malcolm can you ought to
hit it right on top i'm right on the
nail right on the nail
you know republicans have been running
texas for almost 30 years just like
pennsylvania people are sick of their
[ __ ]
you know i happen to be lucky enough to
live far enough on the east side of
texas that i'm on i'm in the eastern
power grid all my fellow texans right
now are are under warnings of rolling
blackouts
how many years is it going to take them
to fix the power grid here in texas
because i guarantee you when ann
richards handed this state over it was
sterling
we took oil money and we had the
infrastructure that was the envy of not
just the this country of the world we
had the best roads best schools best
power grid best of everything
and we've let republicans
run it into the ground
because they don't do the job
they want the personal power they want
to to make the money
but they don't want to do the job
and people are sick of it people are
sick and damn tired of republicans and
all the [ __ ] and the culture wars
and the nonsense they would just want to
hire somebody you know that's how joe
biden got elected be honest with you
people were just sick of republican [ __ ]
they wanted somebody to come in and do
the job and that's what joe biden's
doing it's not sexy it's not glitzy he's
not on tv
you know
capturing the news his attention every
damn day he's just doing the job
and you know texas can flip
it can it you know the
the congress is going to be
an uphill climb to get it done but
people are so damn sick and tired
it's been a long time since we've seen a
sweep anywhere
this could be a sweep year you know the
the polling keeps coming back that uh um
people you know the right right track
we're on track poland what the right
track wrong track polling doesn't tell
you is what they're pissed off about
and right now i tell you every single
person i talk to
if you talk to a republican they're like
well we hate government period
if you talk to somebody on the left
they're like we hate republicans period
so nobody's saying yay republicans are
doing a great job and going into this
election if we work
if we if we if we volunteer if we fight
we we
back our candidates we we donate we
in a phone bank if we do the
work of getting people elected and show
our asses up to vote
this is going to be
a massive democratic year it's gonna
you're gonna see news stories about
anybody remember patrick foley
when when he lost up in washington
refused to believe it
just refused to believe it
back in the 80s there was just this huge
sweep and nobody could believe what just
happened because the poles kept saying
ah you know this really should be a
close one and this at the end there and
we got our asses handed to us because
people were sick of our [ __ ]
30 35 years ago they got tired of us
well folks are tired of republicans now
they are because republicans won't work
and won't do the job better or work will
so paul why why aren't you running
you'd make a great candidate
because if i said i was running
i would fall under a huge number right
ben i would fall under a huge number of
federal regulations immediately
he is not announcing
breaking news texas paul is saying he's
not running
i heard i heard a candidate right there
i've heard a lot of candidates in my
life and and and you gave a great
campaign speech
yeah well run for yourself
well let me tell you something here at
the
minus touch network that is one thing
and i'm going to give jordy a little
plug here
we are unapologetically pro-democracy
go to the midas touch store
store.minustouch.com this is for jordy
use the promo code justice he's got
these new pins over there he's wanting
to he's wanting you guys to grab up
their union made in the usa pro
democracy enamel pens go over there and
and grab you one use the word
justice the promo code for 10 off but we
really are we really are
unapologetically pro-democracy here i i
actually i get a lot of folks that watch
my show that aren't necessarily
democrats right they're they're liberals
or socialists or whatever you would
label them as moderates independence i
believe that they're just pro-democracy
that they want to engage in the
democracy and i think that's the only
way that it works uh ben was talking
about this earlier the only way we keep
democracy is to [ __ ] do democracy
like do the thing that is democracy and
engage in the ballot and i'm not just
talking about marking the the ballot
don't just go mark the ballot engage
talk to folks your family your friends
your that your
your fellow church members the people
who who are the parents of your children
at the school hell the damn lady at the
grocery store who's checking out your
bread talk to them ask them questions
and and more than that they might as
touch well yeah also you know they're
they're there he is pitching uh might as
well
like that but but i think more than
anything engaging in democracy
means that yes it is hard democracy is
hard that's why they love
authoritarianism because it's so easy to
try to pick the person that gives you
whatever you want with a magic wand but
that's not how equality and equity is
delivered that's not how liberty is
delivered to us it is a damn fight it is
difficult and you have to you have to
engage in your democracy and like i said
do the the [ __ ] thing called
democracy just do it yeah
aren't you teamed up with uh is it field
team six for action items that people
can take that are just like
tell people about it i think it's a
great idea yeah so we have a partnership
with a group called field team six which
is out there registering voters and
telling people how you can get involved
in registering voters or sending
postcards to remind people to vote every
week we work with the field team six and
we give the top five midas
recommendations for how you can get
involved in some activity that week
whether it's phone banking or postcard
writing or showing up to a meeting in a
different location you know canvassing
and door knocking we give our five
favorites of the week but there's others
that you can check out there and since
we started that relationship with field
team six with midas touch and field team
six they say they've seen an increase in
participation by over 600 percent
which has been great and i hope we can
get that number up even higher um so
just go check out the midas touch feed
or you can google and look up the
organization field team six voter
registration drive and uh we will post
our picks every week and um you can
follow them at fieldteam6 on twitter
that's fantastic
and i think we have to stay engaged and
this is part of it folks watching these
hearings engaging with these hearings
knowing what they're saying uh
definitely understanding
the what what the hearings mean because
we have all kinds of different meanings
there's the legal meanings like ben
and harry littman and popock and kfa
give us there's the political part of it
which the political strategists like
david benner my friend rachel
biddikoffer give us those political
strategies what it means in politics and
then we have the everyday folks out
there what it means for them where texas
paul and people like jessica give us
insight into this trump campaign and
trump what they do
it's important to engage in this way and
we hope today that while joining us
we've held the audience here all day
long it's we've been setting records
with these audiences um and we've had i
think ben we did the math the other day
it's well over a million views is what
we have had
for the actual broadcast of day one to
day seven now we'll have well probably
close to 1.3 or 1.4 million at this
point put it this way tony if you were
if our youtube channel was a cable news
network
we would be ranking in the top 40 of all
cable shows not just new shows of all
cable shows um for you know for the show
for the week and we obviously don't have
yet uh the cable news network component
we're just streaming on youtube so short
of that element i mean those are
phenomenal numbers and it's growing but
it's a testament to the professionalism
of the panel the professionalism of our
hosts and our executive producer and
tony and gabe and the great work you've
done and why your culture why you just
heard the word yet
oh we don't we don't have a cable news
network yet
so
this and and
just like paul isn't running yet if
you're exactly yeah
i didn't hear sherman
either
paul there's a draft coming you know
let me let me say something to what ben
just said
if you build it they will come and what
the committee did
was they built something and that's why
people are paying attention what this
network is doing is covering it in a way
that gives people a chance to engage in
it
because that's what this is the
democracy part that everyone's talked
about jessica spoke to so eloquently
it's it's getting people engaged
and and keeping them engaged this is
part of that what are you pointing at
paul he's pointing at ben texting
texting how he's googling how how to
open a cable
tv news network right now that's what
i'm saying i'm calling [ __ ] because
i'm going to ask you ben i'm going to
ask you one question then i'm going to
make one quick very quick statement ben
how much have we grown in
the last few months
oh
massively so we're picking up about
three to five thousand subscribers a day
and picked up about another what two
hundred thousand subs texas paul since
we personally hundred and what percent
a hundred and what percent
what other network or
media organization has grown a hundred
over a hundred percent in a couple weeks
and i'll say this texas paul because
this guy and i'm gonna tell you the
truth and this is a short statement i'm
gonna make this guy right here was
sitting there working while the rest of
us were listening to each other and
thinking of the next thing we were going
to say this guy was looking down at his
phone working
and he does it
all the damn time who else here has
gotten a text from this guy at three
o'clock in the morning
anybody who hasn't
yeah who has it right
i haven't figured out when he sleeps and
that's why david i agree with you if you
build it they will come and they are
building it he's working his ass off his
brothers are working their asses off to
make it work and they're bringing in
people that are different from what you
normally see so i'll shut up now
but i just wanted to put that plug out
there ben you're busting ass and i'm
super proud of you
always working that's why he's so skinny
look at him man he's just working
[Laughter]
you know
there's a brotherhood of those two hats
you can see it right yeah yeah i think i
think their brains are melting together
or some [ __ ] i don't know yeah it's
something about that brother's from
another hat you know the hats or some
[ __ ] i don't know i don't know what's
going on
you know
can we go back to the hearings for a
second because there's something that
also struck me that that's really
interesting look at david getting us
back on track here donald trump was
doing something now we've heard it twice
he was naming somebody to a job
telling them they had the job remember
he told jeff clark he was going to be
attorney general it got changed from the
phone logs where you know
acting attorney general clark
and sydney powell
plainly was told she was going to be a
special counsel the president
and and he was doing it and
until he couldn't get away with it until
the adults came into the room said
excuse me there's paperwork involved
but that's what was going on in the last
month of that white house now that's not
a surprise to anyone but we're we're now
getting it documented
and that's really important because when
this stuff
does get written up and and you know
i i hope people understand there's no
need for a criminal referral committee
does not have to make a referral
they're watching the same way we are liz
janey made a referral today just by
saying it out loud all she does is have
to say it out loud there is actually no
legal way other than uh contempt of
congress for them to make a referral but
the referrals in plain sight just like
just like it will be wild was in plain
sight the act of committing a crime was
the tweet inciting to violence
and that's what they're connecting with
the gods now this is the this is this is
the 21st century
exactly will be wild done in a way and
and i thought it was really effective
to
to have the the voice of the twitter
official
who uh you know twitter employee
and a voice we're not allowed to hear or
recognize because he's worried about his
own job still
but i wonder if it's elon i wonder if
it's probably at this point based on
this last weekend
but the other
someone who was scared saying i couldn't
sleep i was on pins and needles because
i knew there was going to be violence
that was enormously smart of this
committee and again hats on
to their ability to to tell a narrative
to make a story
into something real and compelling and
that's what we saw
well i appreciate the commentary there
jessica do you have a finishing
statement and then we'll go to texas
paul and see if texas ben has anything
to say as well
yeah i i feel like i've i've um i'm just
going to beat my drum again about
this american carnage
and and the abuse and abuse of everyone
everyone trump supporters
non-trump supporters the entire country
the world i started off today talking
about how patchy bologna defended trump
an impeachment one he extorted the
country that is now experiencing a
genocide um this is just so destructive
and and
i am i am too grateful as as everybody
else is for the exceptional work of this
committee and their dexterity um their
nimbleness and ability to produce this
in a way that really is is
capturing the public's attention and i'm
really looking forward to the next
hearing because i will never forget the
debut hearing the prime time debut
hearing how visceral
it was it brought us back to that day
just reliving live what was happening
that day and i think that we're going to
come full circle next week
in reliving those moments
of
people beating down the doors of the
capitol um as trump stood by and and
watched it in in glee and um one other
thing that i just remembered i mean just
a just a random note um
how how the staff members the janitors
of the capital many of them
african-americans
were left to clean up
feces and desecration from these people
who donald trump sent just just
it's just such a base disgusting image
to be left with but i
i really think it
captures um
the disregard and disrespect that this
man and his his cult movement have have
perpetuated and caused in this country
texas paul
okay you got the
uber intelligent analysis from this guy
right here yeah
you've got the personal
100 heartfelt
commentary from the inside from this
lovely lady right here
you've got
viral videos from this hilarious guy
right here that's just killing it right
now
knocking my numbers in the dirt i hate
jesus
it's easy when you record phone calls
from don jr yeah yeah you got a podcast
from this guy right here who nails it
all the time
we just talked about my power grid great
work by the way that last podcast
loved it
and then you've got this guy
right over here
who's working his ass off to build
the fastest growing media network in the
country
him
brett
and jordy have been busting their asses
off to make it happen and i am telling
you people if you will subscribe to the
media's mighty
media network had it going didn't i um
you're gonna see something
i like to put it this way when fox came
everybody said there aren't enough crazy
white ring nuts to make fox work
and
you know
murdoch saw something
this guy has figured out that there are
so many people that are tired of paying
their two dollars a month to fox news
that they're cutting the cables that
they are wanting their their news when
they want it
as they want it
where they want it
he has come up with
he and his brothers have come up with a
tremendous
idea that is going to be the next huge
monstrous thing watch it happen watch it
happen
i think you're right when when you say
there's plenty of pro-democracy un
unapologetically
pro-pro-democracy people out there to
create a network and it's not just us
here on the network it's also the people
the midas mighty are are
one of the greatest greatest followings
that there is i've experienced it since
i've joined the midas touch network
so go to store.minustouch.com and show
jordy some love this is this is from
jordy he's got the promo code justice
and he's trying to get these new pins
he's got these pro-democracy pins are
union made in usa
make sure to go over there um because if
i don't if i don't say it enough times
he'll jordy will be on me i'm telling
you he's always on me so ben ben what's
texas ben give us your last word and
then
we'll cut the panel there
well you know i think what we saw today
even to texas paul's point what fox wing
has radicalized what naga has
radicalized are these communities of
hate
communities of blaming other people
right
and so part of what the january 6
committee is doing a major part one of
the reasons with these witnesses today
who managed to extract themselves
from these communities of hate is also
very sophisticated because in exposing
trump as well
sending a message out there to the
public at large that there are safe
spaces that there are other people who
have been able to make it out of this
cult
we know jamie raskins spoken with one of
the podcasters on the midas media
network dr hassan who got out of the
moodies
i mean he's been a piece of phd who
talks about cult deprogramming and one
of the most significant and most
effective ways of culti programming is
showing other people who got out of the
cult and that they were okay and that
they made it and that was another layer
of what was going on today
with those witnesses and what midas
media what the midas community is all
about is
as you've created the social media world
and all of these things real communities
don't really exist anymore um and
because of that and people are longing
for connections they're longing to feel
a part of something
and that's hard to find and so the
demagogues
um as jamie raskin
spoke about in his closing speech and it
would start with the demagogue
is able to
build these communities of hate based on
anger vitriol and all of these negan
racism
we need to create communities of love
and communities of normalcy in
communities that celebrate democracy and
that celebrate peace and families
and just going about things in your day
and and that is
what we all want and
on the one hand you have the snake oil
salesman and these radical extremists
pitching something
and on the pro-democracy fire side for
some time we haven't really had that you
know and so it's just important to
create
the communities of love peace these safe
spaces where people can laugh where
people can go to a baseball game where
people
don't have to worry like we did under
the trump administration that any tweet
could start a nuclear war that any tweet
could you know what's he going to say
today that's going to destroy someone's
life that i know you know that's what we
thought about every day
and so that's what we're creating here
and frankly that's what the january 6
committee is doing also as they operate
from different levels the legal the
political
psychological the human and that's what
we're seeing today and as we've seen
throughout all of the hearings and so
thank you to everybody who's watching it
thanks to an incredible well thank you
panel thank you jessica thank you david
thank you texas paul and thank you texas
been today
maybe we'll have texas been back again
so thank you thank a great panel again
please join us next week for the panel
uh audience stick around i i've got a
few announcements for you thank you
panel thank you very much
uh gabe what what a great hearing yeah
what great this is uh better than better
than i expected oh it's been fantastic
and it's our pleasure to bring you
to bring you this production of the
hearing um we the midas touch network
has been working so hard behind the
scenes not just us but everyone all the
commentators are working very hard so
please follow the minus touch network
right here on youtube you're not going
to want to miss next week's hearing but
between now and then there's going to be
plenty of content and also yeah also go
over and follow
at the tony michael's podcast yeah why
not give it why not give it a like give
it a subscribe
smash that like hit that subscribe
because here's the thing we spread our
pro democracy message on our channel
right five days a week monday through
friday two hours live two hours noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch so you can
subscribe here on youtube and we also we
also simulcast to the midas touch
facebook page so please please go uh hit
the subscribe button on our podcast you
can also download it now if if that
suits your fancy if you don't like to
watch and you like to listen you can
listen to you got it
apple spotify your favorite directory
just go hit download give us give us
some love over on the directories we've
had some trolls really um give us some
bad reviews
so go give us some love and now that we
we've got people out here go give us
some love over on the directories apple
in particular but also don't forget i
got to do this one more time for jordy
one more time
uh please go to store.minustouch.com
jordy myself i gotta pick myself up one
of these pins he's got these brand new
uh unapologetically pro-democracy enamel
pens you know we got rid of the convict
45 or convict-45 i think they sold out
they're done yeah he sold out they were
gone just boom just like that we put up
a little graphic and you give them 10
percent off you just use the promo code
justice over at store.minustouch.com
uh so get jordy to run out of these pens
maybe
who knows what the next one's gonna be
yeah maybe next week he'll have
something different for me if you run
over there and grab you been dave it's
been a great day a great hearing now
we're at five and a half hours strong
here on the midas touch network uh
it's not a record yet though we've no
it's not i know yeah i know we we've
we've done a little longer but uh it's
it's been a long day there's been a lot
of information but i can't wait for next
week so be paying attention again uh
follow the minus touch network here on
youtube go follow him on twitter you can
also follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod and at the tonymichaels
and i am gabe sanchez don't forget to
follow us over there we will bring you
up to date give you the links that you
go to to set your reminders um it looks
like i'm just getting news uh
brett's pinging me now it says just in
uh looks like next week's hearing is
scheduled for thursday night in prime
time so that's um
is that
no for for this thursday see this is
this is all over this thursday all right
that's what i thought this is all over
the map so it looks like we are going to
have possibly a hearing this thursday so
stay tuned if we do confirm that there
is a hearing folks on thursday we will
get that link out as soon as possible so
that you guys have that link to go set
your reminder again follow uh and
subscribe to
midas touch uh network here on youtube
well yeah yeah once we once we confirm
once we have the info then we will we
will send it out whether it's this week
or next week right
until we get the final word from the
january 6 committee again subscribe here
on the minus touch network and you will
be able to set a reminder once that
happens now again they kind of changed
the time on us on today so we had it set
yeah one time then we had to change the
time which which you know goes to what
uh uh david bender and i were talking
about which is like you know you're
producing this thing it is very much on
the fly especially when you have you
know thanks to people like cassidy
hutchinson coming forward giving their
testimony
and making others feel like they can do
that right that they don't have to feel
afraid or worried that there might be
some sort of
uh um
you know uh negative feedback right from
from the mag occult um and i think it
kind of goes to saying how
how not so tight of a grip trump has
anymore right like knowing like that
grip is loosening where people now feel
like they have the ability and space to
go out and speak
without any sort of fear or any sort of
worry and so i think you know we saw
that with simpoloni you know we're going
to see it with other people we have a
witness that we have not even heard of i
don't know if they're new or if they're
old and they're just waiting to kind of
put the cherry on top we had this with
this idea that maybe there would be a
witness sarah matthews the deputy press
secretary maybe that's the witness i
don't know it's all up in the air yeah
it could be it could be whatever we
still have to see footage from the
documentary which now has been released
on discussion i think you gotta have
more than one more hearing it really
feels like to me i mean if i if i were
them and obviously knowing the goal here
is to warn america from this happening
again in making sure that those involved
in that administration or tangentially
uh involved in that administration even
not like directly in the planning of the
coup
but making sure that those who are
trying to do this again you know trying
to revisit and make this a sequel aren't
able to and so whether they're trying to
move this out closer and closer to the
midterms so be it i don't have a problem
with that right it's political it's
political and we said on our show
politicize the [ __ ] yeah i mean people
have short attention spans i have adhd
if i don't have it in front of me i
might forget it tony can tell you when
we've had meetings
my brain is all over the place trying to
keep this guy on track
not focused on making fake documents is
horrible it's horrible
but if it can be closer to the midterms
to remind people exactly what they're
voting for and what they're fighting for
which is democracy
then so be it i would much rather have
it that way so that it becomes one of
these things where it's you know every
week as hey this week on the
insurrection and it's more details and
i'm sure more and more will come out and
we'll get the full final report sometime
in 2023
but at least we were able to watch it
live we weren't able to do that with the
mueller report and we kind of talked
about that at the beginning of the show
which is
people were able to uh brush off the
mueller report and say that's fake news
or it's this a propaganda whatever
and this time we're able to watch the
january 6 happen in real time and
actually watch the hearings in real time
and see the evidence that are there
under oath with these people coming
forward well i i think you're right and
i think we
everyone listening out there please pay
attention again subscribe to the minus
touch network
youtube channel that link will be there
for you to set a reminder also you can
go follow mydistouch on twitter you can
follow us at tonymichael's pod at the
tony michaels and that i am gabe sanchez
for all the updates on the production of
the next hearing whenever it shall be
we will have it there thank you for
joining us today
until until the next hearing good day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you